On March 15th, 2011, Martin Sims was wandering
down the streets of Carson, California. His
clothes were ragged, he was filthy, and gibbering
like a madman with a full beard and long, unkempt
hair. His body was covered in scars, but he showed
no signs of malnutrition. What made Martin’s
sudden appearance so remarkable? He’d been
missing for three years. When he was interviewed
by police, they asked him where he’d been all this
time. They couldn’t believe his answer. He’d been
trapped in an Ikea since 2008. But this was no
ordinary Ikea – this was a dangerous anomaly
that would come to be known as SCP-3008 .
Martin’s strange answers in his interview
were laughed off by his interviewing officers,
who assumed he was either crazy or under the
influence of something, but they caught
the attention of an SCP Foundation Field
Agent embedded in the precinct. The report was
passed up the chain to a local Site Director,
who approved a detachment of Foundation Field
Operatives to look into Martin’s case. While he
was reluctant to lead the Foundation Agents back
to the offending Ikea – the Foundation can be
extremely persuasive. His screams of “Please, I’m
begging you, don’t take me back! Don’t make me go
back!” were noted but ultimately disregarded.
When the SCP Foundation had triangulated the
position of SCP-3008 , which was indeed
an active Ikea, the entire retail zone was
closed and barricaded under the pretence of a
severe black mold infestation. Armed Foundation
Personnel also arrived on site shortly after,
based on Martin’s vague statements that there
were creatures of some kind inside. Due to his
deteriorating mental health, Martin was unable
to provide a great deal of lucid information on
the specific traits of SCP-3008 , but one phrase
he kept repeating was “bigger on the inside.”
Once researchers were satisfied that Martin had
delivered all the pertinent information he
was able to, he was administered Foundation
Amnestics to erase his memory of the last three
years and returned to his family. A cover story
was formulated: Martin had been kidnapped and
abused for three years by a mentally-unbalanced
stalker in downtown Carson. He’d been able to
escape as said stalker took his own life out of
guilt – a suicide that the Foundation expertly
fabricated to make their cover story airtight.
With the loose end of Martin Sims taken care of,
the true observation of SCP-3008 could begin.
A base set around the perimeter of the mysterious
Ikea kept a 24-hour watch on the building,
covering all potential entrances and exits. No
exploratory missions had yet been approved by
the Foundation ethics committee, so they first
wanted to perform a week of external observation
to see if any of the store’s anomalous
properties extended beyond the confines
of the building. After a week of nothing, it
appeared they did not. A local Site Director
approved the use of twenty disposable Class-D
Personnel to explore the interior of SCP-3008 .
The D-Class operatives would be split into
four squads of five men – Alpha, Bravo,
Charlie, and Delta Squad. Each would be assigned a
different quadrant of the store, and would deliver
information back to the control team on site via
a live audio and video link. Three of the four
teams, upon entering the store, reported nothing
out of the ordinary. Neither the audio or video
they were sending back indicated anything
different from a standard Ikea store – from
the flat-pack wardrobes to the Swedish meatballs.
Team Delta, however, suddenly began experiencing
a scrambled audio and video connection.
Shortly after, communication with Team
Delta dropped off entirely. They disappeared
somewhere inside the store, and haven’t been
seen since – with one notable exception. After
the disappearance of the extraction of teams,
Foundation Researchers classified SCP-3008 as
Euclid, because its anomalous properties were at
least confined to the interior of the store. And
even then, seemingly not the entire interior. The
anomalous area within SCP-3008 became known as
SCP-3008-1, and containment appeared to be 100%
secure. There was no telling how many people had
already gone missing in the store over the years,
but the disappearances must be stopped.
The Foundation maintained constant
surveillance around the perimeter of SCP-3008
, but it appeared they could prevent any
further “incidents” by simply preventing other
civilians from accessing the Ikea store. Martin’s
ravings about monsters were assumed to just
be the product of delirium. Until a surviving
member of Delta Team suddenly reappeared.
The date was November 3rd, 2011. It was a
cold night, a few hours after what would have
been closing time if the store were still active
and seven months after the extraction teams had
disappeared somewhere in the confines of SCP-3008.
There had been no anomalous activity outside
the store since the perimeter was first secured,
and Foundation researchers hadn’t expected that to
change, until the last surviving member of Delta
Team came barging out of the store’s entrance.
Startled Field Operatives were amazed to see
him again, but they were even more amazed to
see what was following him out of the store,
repeating the same phrase: “The store is
now closed, please exit the building.”
Despite the fact that the entity chasing the
Delta Team survivor was wearing the yellow shirt
and blue pants of an Ikea store employee, the
being was definitely not human. It was around
seven feet tall, with no visible face. The entity
had grossly extended limbs – with each arm being
around five or six feet long, and ending in
a huge, oversized hand. The whole process
was so sudden that the Field Agents present at
the perimeter weren’t able to save the Delta
Team survivor, as the entity reached forward
with its freakishly long arms, grabbed him,
and twisted his head off like a child with a doll.
The Field Operatives present drew their weapons
and peppered the entity with bullets. It would
later be classified as SCP-3008-2. The being
appeared to collapse and die from the physical
trauma, at which point both it and the body of
the former Delta Team survivor were taken
for an autopsy by Foundation researchers.
There were no biological abnormalities
to the body of the Delta Team survivor,
so it did not appear that the anomalous properties
of SCP-3008-1 had any effect on the physiology
of its occupants. He was not malnourished despite
being missing for months, and the contents of his
stomach looked to be half-digested food consistent
with the menu of a typical Ikea store restaurant.
SCP-3008-2, on the other hand, raised a number
of perplexing biological questions. The autopsy
revealed that the creature’s clothes were actually
a part of its body, like an additional layer of
skin. The creature lacked blood or any kind of
vascular system. Even stranger, the entity didn’t
appear to have any bones or internal organs, not
even a brain or nervous system. It was a being
made entirely of skin, all the way to its core.
How it was able to move, or even live for that
matter, remains a mystery. Though when you work
for The SCP Foundation, you learn to accept that
some things will always remain unexplained.
One thing was certain, though:
Martin Sims was right about his monsters.
After the incident with Delta Team, the Foundation
deemed that sending manned explorations into the
heart of SCP-3008 was too much of a liability,
and planned a series of drone-based reconnaissance
missions into the anomaly. The first of these
drones experienced connection issues and
failed when attempting to venture into the
Ikea’s anomalous zone. However, after a lengthy
period of trial and error, the Foundation was
able to establish a more secure connection with
its drones, even when deep into the SCP-3008-1
anomalous zone. It was only then that some of
the most extraordinary discoveries were made.
SCP-3008-1 seemed to break the laws of spatial
reality, as the area of the Ikea’s interior was
at least an order of magnitude larger than
its exterior. Just as Martin Sims had said:
It was bigger on the inside. But just how much
bigger? The Foundation has yet to find evidence
of any physical terminators within the store that
might indicate SCP-3008-1 has an “end point.”
While an area of at least ten kilometres
squared has been uncovered in SCP-3008-1,
it could – in theory – be infinite. Laser
rangefinder tests, which are normally very
reliable, have only given inconclusive results.
Interestingly, the anomalous area doesn’t have
any clear, visual differences from the rest of
the Ikea store except that it extends forever.
An individual trapped within the confines of
SCP-3008-1 wouldn’t even realize that they’d
entered an anomalous zone until they tried
to locate an exit and leave, at which point,
they’d find they were already hopelessly lost. The
geography of SCP-3008-1 does at least appear to be
consistent, so people trapped within are
theoretically able to retrace their steps and
escape if they hadn’t already ventured too deep.
According to data collected during the drone
reconnaissance missions, SCP-3008-2, of
which there appeared to be a vast population,
would wander the stores aimlessly during the day.
They were unresponsive to the drone’s presence,
and did not appear to be aggressive. While the
physical descriptions of these creatures could
vary slightly, they all followed the same overall
trend: “Clothes” consistent with the Ikea uniform,
no face, either seemingly too tall or
too short, and limbs that are grossly
out of proportion with their bodies.
As the Foundation began sending drones
deeper into SCP-3008-1, they found another
incredible discovery. There was an unknown
population of humans trapped inside the
Ikea’s anomalous zone, and these people
had used the Ikea furniture around them to
create entire settlements and towns within
the store. There were several of these towns,
all of which seemed to cohabitate peacefully.
Even Foundation personnel found this development
in their research to be truly extraordinary.
Since SCP-3008 was first identified, there
have been only fourteen civilian escapes.
Some had been trapped inside for months, others
had been in there for years – some far longer
than Martin’s three-year stint. While every one
of these escapees has eventually been released
back to their home, after a liberal application
of Amnestics and a proper cover story has been
devised, the Foundation interviewed each of them
extensively first. According to these escapees,
the people trapped inside the Ikea
have built an entirely new society
across the various settlements.
Contrary to the “Lord of the Flies”
expectations of a group of people isolated and
afraid, there’s immense cooperation between the
trapped civilians. The food in the several Ikea
restaurants in SCP-3008-1 mysteriously replenishes
while nobody is there, so there’s no threat of
starving. And the automatic turning on and off
of the lights forms a kind of rudimentary
day and night cycle. Night time, however,
is when things get dangerous, as the SCP-3008-2
entities – which are known to the people inside as
“The Staff” – become extremely hostile after dark.
Aggressive hordes of the Staff swarm the
settlements at night, repeating “The store
is now closed, please exit the building.”
The civilians inside are usually able to
repel these attacks with minimal casualties,
but the constant war of attrition slowly wears
down those inside. The bodies of the creatures
also need to be removed from the area after each
attack, as the presence of corpses or even parts
of corpses has been known to heighten the ferocity
of the next night’s attack. During the day,
the Staff return to a docile and unresponsive
state, though they’ll still defend themselves
violently if anyone dares to attack.
Over the course of the interviews with the
fourteen escapees, Foundation Researchers were
able to answer another of their key questions:
How had so many people gone missing in the store
for so long without being noticed? But the answer
they received only raised many more unsettling
queries. According to the escapees, there were
people inside the settlements that, despite being
otherwise of entirely sound mind and standard
intelligence, seemed to lack very common knowledge
that even a child should know. For example,
some weren’t aware of the International Space
Station orbiting the earth, or stranger still,
the existence of the Statue of Liberty.
This led the Researchers to a frightening
conclusion: SCP-3008-1 may not only be a nexus
point of multiple Ikea stores in our dimension,
it could be connected to Ikeas in every
dimension where Ikeas exist. While it only
abducts a handful of people from each store over
an extended period of time, it suddenly becomes
clear how this SCP was able to trap so many people
without detection over such a long period of time.
Which, in turn, led to an even more terrifying
revelation: The SCP Foundation may not have
SCP-3008-1 as contained as they thought. It might
even be tucked away in an Ikea somewhere near you,
just waiting for you to visit. After
all, there’s always room for one more…
An SCP Foundation researcher sits at a
table inside of a standard containment
cell. These are often dangerous places to
be, especially when the SCP you’re supposed
to be studying is one that you can’t
see. The researcher is taking notes,
unsure of exactly what’s going to happen next.
He can hear the sounds of knives scraping behind,
of flesh sizzling and searing from high heat. He
braces himself as a burst of heat hits the back
of his head, as if a fireball has erupted. Just
then it happens - an object floats through the
air and settles in front of him on the table.
It’s a plate of food, and it looks delicious.
It may surprise you to learn that there is
no rule that the SCP Foundation must deal
exclusively with violent and vicious creatures.
Not every SCP held in containment shares the same
malevolence and contempt for humanity as SCP-682,
or the world-ending threat posed by the likes of
SCP-2317. Some - perhaps not many, but some - are
benign and might even seem outwardly friendly,
but you’d still be taking a huge risk
to assume that anything contained by the
SCP Foundation is completely harmless.
Such is the case with SCP-5031. As per
the Foundation’s containment procedures, this
quasi-humanoid – meaning it appears to have some
vaguely human features - is held in an airtight
cell that is regularly checked by Foundation
personnel on a bi-weekly basis. SCP-5031 has no
need for regular nutrition or regular interactions
from staff. The trick with SCP-5031, is not being
eaten by it, since though it doesn’t need food,
it does still hunt and consume anything
it encounters - human or otherwise.
Avoiding being eaten is hard enough with
creatures that can actually be seen,
but like so many other creatures the Foundation
keeps contained, SCP-5031 has developed an
almost-perfect defense mechanism - which is that
when observed, it will literally cease to exist.
Some might choose to refer to this as a ‘quantum
lock’, however it is worth noting that traces
left by SCP-5031 still remain observable when the
creature has temporarily disappeared. For example,
trails of blood and scratch marks left behind by
SCP-5031 still exist when the SCP itself does not.
Naturally, this makes both avoiding the creature
and capturing it using cameras difficult. However,
when SCP-5031’s existence ceases
it still casts a shadow. From this,
researchers have been able to determine
several of the creature’s physical traits.
Based on its silhouette, it has been deduced
that SCP-5031 levitates about half a meter
above ground level, it sports an abnormally
small, neckless head atop an elongated
torso - approximately 1.9 meters long - with three
sets of spindly lower arms that branch outwards.
Using these arms and its loosely hanging
body, SCP-5031 will lower itself to hunt
any human or animal that draws near to it
and uses the bladelike tail to cut up food.
Perhaps the most interesting facet of SCP-5031
beyond its defensive capabilities and apparent
physical attributes, are the series of nine tests
conducted by Senior Researcher Stanley Huxtable.
Appalled by the conditions that the creature was
being kept in, Huxtable took over the role of HCL
Supervisor for SCP-5031. Having grown increasingly
frustrated and empathetic towards the creature,
listening to its screams from inside its
iron containment unit, Huxtable devised a
series of tests to introduce SCP-5031 to various
different stimuli as a way to better understand
the creature and hopefully keep it contained in a
way that didn’t seem to cause so much suffering.
It's worth remembering that the SCP Foundation
makes it its mission to be cold, not cruel,
in performing their duties to protect normality
and many of the researchers and staff are just as
capable of having empathy for creatures as
you might for a stray animal at a shelter.
The first of Huxtable’s tests involved
installing speakers in SCP-5031’s cell,
through which a variety of different ambient and
popular pieces of music were played to see if
they had any effect on reducing the creature’s
stress. By judging SCP-5031’s stress levels
based on how much it screamed when compared to
normal, Huxtable was able to determine how to
best to use music to calm the creature. SCP-5031
seemed to convey higher levels of stress when
listening to ‘Morning Forest’, ‘Deep Grotto’
and ‘Seaside Paradise’ ambience, as well as the
best of late 60s British rock band Jethro Tull.
However, the best of Mozart, Enya, KISS and Ben
Folds produced dramatically different results,
decreasing SCP-5031’s apparent stress. Following
this test, Senior Researcher Huxtable compiled
a playlist featuring SCP-5031’s favorite music.
Over time, the stress-reducing effects of music
on SCP-5031 seemed to decrease, but keeping the
playlist on shuffle seemed to keep the creature
consistently calmer than it had been previously.
The next test involved introducing inanimate
objects into SCP-5031’s enclosure to monitor its
reactions and how its stress levels were affected.
When a softball was thrown into the enclosure,
SCP-5031 immediately sliced the ball in two with
its tail in one swift motion. A similar result
occurred when researchers threw the creature a
basketball, which was quickly punctured and sliced
open by SCP-5031’s tail. Its stress levels
first seemed to diminish when the creature
was offered a bowling ball, which it rolled
around the enclosure and then later knocked
against a second bowling ball. However, when
one of the balls chipped, rendering it unable
to roll properly, SCP-5031’s stress increased
dramatically, until a replacement was offered.
Researcher Huxtable noted that SCP-5031 seemed
to possess a similar level of motor skills to
an average human toddler, with similarly
explosive emotional reactions to match.
Next, when given the choice between two food
sources at opposite ends of its enclosure,
SCP-5031 seemed to gravitate towards
higher-quality food, most notably favoring
cooked rotisserie chickens over animal carcasses.
It even chose this option over a live chicken,
using its tail to cut its food into more
manageable bite-sized portions, rather than
ripping its meat with its hands or teeth like many
of its fellow SCPs. Researcher Huxtable recorded
these findings and highlighted that, even though
SCP-5031 didn’t need to eat in order to survive,
providing the creature with food of a better
quality marginally reduced its stress.
Senior Researcher Huxtable next attempted to test
SCP-5031’s coexistence with other living subjects,
each time making sure that the creature had been
adequately fed to avoid any unseemly incidents.
First, a live chicken was introduced.
SCP-5031 rolled its bowling ball at
high speed towards the chicken, increasing
both its and the chicken’s stress levels,
and inadvertently killing the chicken in the
process. When a second chicken was introduced,
SCP-5031 gently rolled a basketball towards it but
ceased any further engagement after the chicken
squawked from being hit by the ball. Next to be
introduced into the enclosure was a blindfolded
D Class staff member, who was instructed to sit
down and roll the basketball towards SCP-5031.
After doing so for several minutes, the
creature began to approach the D class subject,
who was instructed to remove their blindfold to
cease the creature’s existence and prevent any
potentially deadly incidents. Finally, Researcher
Huxtable had another Class-D engage in a game of
catch with SCP-5031 while facing away from the
creature. This test proceeded successfully, and
Senior Researcher Huxtable remarked how SCP-5031’s
motor skills were improving. Albeit gradually,
and with some gentle encouragement, through
Huxtable’s tests the creature was learning.
The next test, focused on teaching SCP-5031
linguistic symbols, utilized LCD displays and
buttons connected to a food dispenser.
One display showed an image of a rock,
and the other an image of a rotisserie chicken.
After some brief probing, SCP-5031 was quickly
able to understand that pressing the button
under the correct display would dispense a
rotisserie chicken for it to eat. The creature
was later able to adapt when, the following day,
the screen displays and materials dispensed
were swapped, and then later set to swap at
random intervals. When additional rock-dispensing
stations were introduced, this time displaying the
word ‘rock’ as opposed to an image, SCP-5031
was able to determine which station dispensed
‘chicken’ through a process of elimination.
Whenever the functions and displays were swapped,
SCP-5031 would find whichever displayed the
word ‘chicken’ to receive its food. The final
phase of this test presented SCP-5031 with a
single station, displaying the word ‘chicken’,
but with a button that would remain inactive
unless the creature spelled out the same word
with a collection of lettered blocks it was
provided with. After some initial confusion
and frustration as to why the button would not
dispense food when pressed, SCP-5031 was able
to assemble the word correctly, not only
activating the button and dispensing food,
but proving to Researcher Huxtable that the
creature was capable of learning language.
Huxtable continued to test the creature,
encouraging it to spell words using lettered
blocks as a method of communicating. By
increasing SCP-5031’s vocabulary and the
amount of human interaction it received,
Senior Researcher Huxtable observed that
SCP-5031 was gradually learning to sing -
albeit nonverbally - as well as to juggle
with its six hands and was even communicating
its own food preferences and dish pairings.
Later, another Class-D, D-52125, was introduced
to SCP-5031’s enclosure to aid in further
testing. Through D-52125’s instructions, the
creature quickly learned to draw using crayons,
and created artworks depicting itself, its
newfound friend D-52125, Researcher Huxtable,
a cat and a rotisserie chicken.
SCP-5031’s new creative side didn’t
stop there though, as the creature quickly
learned to play Chopsticks in only two days
once a piano was introduced into the enclosure.
SCP-5031 even managed to start creating its own
original, admittedly crude, compositions.
Next, a spice rack was placed inside the
creature’s cell and D-52125 demonstrated how
to season meat. This proved to be SCP-5031’s
new favorite hobby, as it spent the next
three days experimenting with different
combinations of foods and spices, using
its letter blocks to request ‘more, more,
more’ garlic powder. Interestingly, the creature
only created artwork or music when D-52125 was
present, but seemed to thoroughly enjoy its
experimentation with food when left alone.
Following this development, Senior Researcher
Huxtable devised a new test for SCP-5031.
Providing the creature with cooking utensils and
using D-52125 to demonstrate, 5031 was shown how
to prepare a variety of different dishes, from
hamburgers and tacos, to Mongolian Beef, steak,
clam chowder and profiteroles. In addition to a
small peanut allergy, this eighth test revealed
SCP-5031 to be a phenomenal chef, possessing
culinary skills far beyond the average person.
The creature quickly and enthusiastically embraced
its newfound talents, concocting its very own
brand-new recipes, with D-52125 even volunteering
to be the first to taste test 5031’s dishes.
It was shortly after this test that
SCP-5031 spoke its very first word,
and it should come as no surprise that the
word was ‘salt’. Naturally, Senior Researcher
Huxtable was very proud of the progress
the creature had made with its development.
The final test almost seemed to be what the
creature was born for. Over the course of two
months, SCP-5031 was tasked with creating a full
three-course meal which would then be served to
Foundation staff for Thanksgiving.
SCP-5031 not only rose to the task,
but exceeded all of Researcher Huxtable’s
expectations, creating a meal that even
Gordon Ramsey would be hard pressed to find
fault with. The creature created a first course
consisting of sweet potato miso soup seasoned
with turmeric. Next came a beautiful duck confit,
glazed luxuriously with apple cider and topped
generously with sweet cranberry compote, paired
with a side of butternut squash gnocchi and served
on a bed of kale seasoned with truffle salt.
The grand finale of the exquisite meal
was a spiced cassava pie for dessert,
complemented with the finest French vanilla
ice cream and a maple-hazelnut syrup.
And SCP-5031 didn’t stop there, the creature
also debuted one of its original musical
compositions to compliment the decadent meal
it had created. As the staff enjoyed the food,
SCP-5031 performed live from its enclosure the
deeply moving Piano Concerto for Six Hands,
to an overwhelmingly positive response
from not only Senior Researcher Huxtable,
but the entire Foundation staff. As a fitting end
to the creature’s tale, Huxtable reported that,
during the Thanksgiving banquet it had created,
SCP-5031’s stress levels reduced entirely.
New kinder containment measures that
would keep 5031 safer but also far
more contented were submitted for approval.
Perhaps some of you may find it refreshing
to learn that SCP-5031 isn’t simply just another
malicious, malevolent monster that the Foundation
has to keep under lock and key for the safety
of the world. Instead, SCP-5031 is a gentle – if
a little frightening at first creature - that
just requires careful and considered guidance
instead of a cold iron cage and around-the-clock
armed guards. Through testing, Senior Researcher
Stanley Huxtable and his fellow Foundation staff
were not only able to help the creature develop,
but also found what makes it tick; and not just
for the purposes of containing it. Instead,
it is hoped that SCP-5031’s creativity and
flair for culinary and musical masterpieces
can continue to thrive and grow, under
the proud watch of Researcher Huxtable.
Over fifty men and women, clad in red robes,
kneel before an unholy altar. They chant and
mutter indecipherable words - words of cruelty and
madness… of obsession and sacrilege. Not long ago,
these were regular people. Computer technicians,
teachers, plumbers, construction workers,
accountants. This was before they fell
under the ungodly influence of a new
ruler. The center of this makeshift place of
worship was once a normal school gymnasium,
but it’s now the home of a huge statue. A
humanoid being, wreathed in tentacles. Its
head is more like a squid or cuttlefish than
anything resembling an actual human face.
While he’s known to the cultists as the Tentacled
God, the beast they worship is known to the SCP
Foundation as SCP - 2662, and he sits in the belly
of one of their expansive containment facilities,
locked away from the world. But not for long,
if his devoted followers have anything to say
about it. This is their god, all-powerful and
unchanging, and when it comes to springing
him from containment, no tactic is too
vile or underhanded to get the job done.
Their mortal leader and high-priest, a man in
a purple robe calling himself Brother Marsh,
walks among their crouched forms. He whispers
instructions for the great day of liberation
that’s soon to come, providing everyone plays
their part. It’s a plan months in the making - and
one that, if it goes off without a hitch, could
free their monstrous god into the world. They
would strike at the very heart of their enemy,
The SCP Foundation, when they least expect it,
and nothing shall stand in their way. How could
they lose when they have a god on their side?
But why did all these normal people become
violent zealots for squid-faced deity? It all
began with a dream. To those who experienced
these dreams, they felt more like prophecies,
premonitions of the glorious horrors to come.
A red sky, billions dead and billions more
enslaved. A dark silhouette on the horizon
- Their Tentacled God, holding dominion over
all. At first, it just seemed like a strange
nightmare. The ones who experienced it woke
up shaken and afraid, hoping to shake the
images from their mind. But they couldn’t.
Every night, the nightmare would return. They’d
see the images - the red sky, the dead and
enslaved, the Tentacled God. And after a while it
would come to them even when they weren’t asleep,
eventually happening whenever they closed their
eyes. Little by little, this scene stopped looking
so hideous… and started to look glorious. They
felt his presence in their minds, slowly pushing
them towards their inevitable future. They started
to realize that they wanted him to rule over the
universe, and to experience the honor of
serving him. Many of them abandoned their
homes and families - leaving their friends and
loved ones left to worry that they’d gone insane.
In their eyes, they were safer
than they’d ever been. They finally
had purpose. They were working in service
of something far greater than themselves.
The influence of the tentacled god drew them
closer to one another. They would meet in secret,
exchanging information from the prophecies their
ruler sent them in their dreams. They worshipped
together, building altars and idols to congregate
around. They performed dark blood rituals,
involving human and animal sacrifice. It
was when Brother Marsh, The Anointed One,
arrived to guide them towards their true
mission that things kicked into high gear.
Just three months prior, Brother Marsh had been
an office drone working in data entry for a large
insurance company, before the Tentacled God
invaded his thoughts with a simple message:
“FREE ME, AND THE NEW WORLD I CREATE
SHALL BE YOUR PLAYGROUND.” Since then,
he’d devoted himself completely to the
cause, quitting his job and maxing out
his credit cards to help fund his new life’s
purpose - infiltrating the SCP Foundation,
and releasing his inhuman
ruler from its imprisonment.
That was the single goal he
united the cultists under:
Freedom for the Tentacled God. And at long
last, they had all the pieces in place to
strike. They’d finally gathered the necessary
intel to subvert the will of the most powerful
secret organization on earth. Even the
strongest institution is made of people,
and people are weak. Unlike the almighty
Tentacled God, people could be broken.
The people in question were Kelly Thompson,
Sidney Levitt, Jordan Brosh, Dr. Juan Gutierrez,
and Gillian Larson. Dr. Juan Gutierrez
was a researcher with Level 3 clearance
on the site where the Tentacled God was being
contained. Sidney Levitt and Jordan Brosh were
both Security Officers charged with verifying
personnel clearance on site. Kelly Thompson
was a member of Site Administration
with research authorization powers,
and Gillian Larson was a research assistant
who often collaborated with Dr. Gutierrez.
These five were the key to getting access to
SCP-2662 and bringing their plan to fruition.
Normally, personnel dossiers on people working
for the Foundation were highly confidential,
but the Devotees of the Tentacled God had their
ways. They had a number of computer experts in
their ranks more than capable of hacking in and
pulling some basic information off of Foundation
servers without being detected. For the other
information they needed they turned to some good,
old-fashioned torture, which is often the most
effective method when you need some quick results.
Of course, while the cult’s grip on
sanity may have been a little tenuous,
they weren’t stupid. While gathering their intel,
they also made sure to find out what exactly they
were up against. SCP-2662 was being held in
a humanoid containment cell, and guarded by
on-site Task Force TAU-9, better known as the
“Belligerent Bodyguards.” These aren’t lazy,
donut-chomping mall cops - these are a heavily
trained, heavily armed fighting force. Though the
cultists had one thing that these Foundation
soldiers didn’t: The element of surprise.
For everything to go off perfectly, Brother
Marsh’s plans would have to be executed within a
single day, and they were already on the clock.
TAU-9 had been charged with tracking down any
new SCP - 2662 cults and dismantling them, and
Brother Marsh knew that it was only a matter of
time before the Foundation tracked them down and
did the same to them. If they wanted any chance
of freeing the Tentacled God, then they needed
to strike quickly and with overwhelming force.
The SCP-2662 worshippers were able to secure the
addresses of the five key Foundation personnel,
and station members outside each of them -
including one who could realistically imitate
each. They waited for night to fall, and broke
into each of their homes as they slept. What
followed was a sequence of ruthless and efficient
murders done in the cause of freeing their god.
Dr. Gutierrez was shot in the head while he
slept. Sidney Levitt and Jordan Brosh were
both stabbed to death before either even
realized what was happening. Thompson,
who’d gotten up to use the bathroom, went
down in a hail of machine gun fire. Gillian
Larson had seen that masked figures were
breaking into her home and attempted to flee,
but was caught and beaten to death by cultists
in her hallway. It was a strange irony that
people whose day jobs entailed working with
some of the most dangerous and nightmarish
anomalies imaginable were murdered in their
homes by nothing more than regular humans.
So far, Brother Marsh’s plan had gone
perfectly, with all five key personnel
murdered within a two minute period. Next,
the selected doppelgängers stole clothes
from their victims’ closets and were handed the
correct forged documentation. The next morning,
each replacement began their journeys to the
site where the Tentacled God was being contained,
while the rest of the cult armed themselves
in preparation for their own part in the plan.
Nobody at the Foundation seemed to notice
anything amiss when the five arrived on site.
When you work for the SCP Foundation, more
mental energy is devoted to following the
rules that keep you alive than to memorizing
the faces of all your co-workers and each one
slipped neatly into position, disappearing
into the familiarity of office life. But,
infiltrating the site was one thing,
getting past the Belligerent Bodyguards
and into the cell of the Tentacled
God would be another thing entirely.
That’s where the rest of the cult would come
into play. Heavily armed with whatever firearms
they could get their hands on, the rest of
the Devotees of the Tentacled God - Brother
Marsh included - would attack the containment site
head-on. In the ensuing chaos, the five cultists
who had already infiltrated the site could take
advantage of the distraction, and break into the
containment chamber. It was perfect. They’d launch
their attack from the outside… and from within.
When Brother Marsh declared that the time
was right, the assault began. A legion of
gun-wielding cultists seemed to spring out of
nowhere and started shooting up the warehouse
that was a front for the containment site.
The site quickly mobilized guards and task
force members to take on the sudden threat, and
just as Brother Marsh had anticipated, the Site
Director called on the majority of TAU-9 to help
repel the violent cultists from their perimeter.
TAU-9 obeyed, leaving three task force
members behind to guard SCP - 2662’s
containment chamber. They expected to
be guarding the cell from rampaging
religious zealots seeking an audience
with their god. What they didn’t expect
was a group of five Foundation employees
walking right up to them and opening fire,
killing two TAU-9 members and taking the third as
a hostage. While the war was being waged outside,
the infiltrators had found the Tentacled God’s
containment cell in the low-risk humanoid ward.
Their hostage insisted that using him
wouldn’t give them any leverage - the
rest of his team would neutralize
the whole group, him included,
if that’s what it took to stop them.
The infiltrators explained that using
him as leverage was never their intention - he
wasn’t a hostage at all. He was a sacrifice.
The cultists of the Tentacled God detonated
explosives, creating a hole in the wall and
finally giving them access to their deity. They
climbed through and gazed upon him in awe. There
stood SCP-2662, twice as tall as a regular man,
with ten huge tentacles emerging from its back.
In their months of envisioning this creature,
they’d pictured it sitting on a throne made
of thousands of human bones, ready to dictate
its commands to the obedient liberators. What
they certainly didn’t expect was to see the
Tentacled God hunched over a computer screen.
Still, gods work in mysterious ways, so they stuck
to the plan and began chanting. They pulled out a
sacrificial dagger, and began sacrificing their
captured TAU-9 member. It was at this point that
SCP - 2662 turned and saw what they were doing
with a look of pure horror. He rose up from his
computer, his headphones getting caught as he
did so. He told them to go away, that he didn’t
want them here, and that them murdering people
in his bedroom like this was inconsiderate and
disgusting. The cultists became even more
confused - why wasn’t their god accepting
their offerings? What were they doing wrong?
They tried more chanting, and painting arcane
symbols on the floor in blood, but this just
seemed to make the creature angrier. He told them,
in a tone more fitting for a teenage boy than a
Lovecraftian God, to just leave him alone so he
could play his video games. This was seriously
not cool! The cultists were baffled. They told
the Tentacled God they were there to free
him. He replied that he didn’t need saving.
That crazy stalkers like them were why he turned
himself in to the Foundation in the first place!
Before the cultist infiltrators could get another
word in, the remaining members of TAU-9 stormed
into the containment cell and gunned them down
with surgical precision. The war outside was
already over - Brother Marsh and the rest of
the cultists were all killed in the firefight.
TAU-9 didn’t look the least bit surprised
upon entering 2662’s cell, this was a common
occurrence unfortunately. They had to deal with
an attempted cult invasion every few months,
because SCP-2662’s main anomalous
ability is inspiring violent cults
who relentlessly track down and worship
it with arcane and bloodthirsty rituals.
The problem is, 2662 doesn’t do this consciously,
and definitely doesn’t like the results. That’s
why he’s under the voluntary care of the SCP
Foundation who keeps him amused with video
games and reading material while fending off the
deranged cults who try to invade and abduct him.
Following the termination of The Devotees of the
Tentacled God, just one of many cults who’d broken
into 2662’s containment cell, the remaining
TAU-9 members apologized to the tentacled
creature for the disturbance, allowing him to
return to his gaming. They assured him that
it’d probably be at least a few more months
before something like this happened again.
SCP-2662’s cell was repaired,
and the Foundation returned
to its task of seeking out would-be cultist
emancipators, because for the SCP Foundation,
it’s not always about the anomaly that’s being
kept in containment, but what’s being kept out.
Mobile Task Force Edna-84, also known by
the code name “And Thus Upon His Crucible”,
is on one of the strangest missions they’ve
ever been sent on. They sit in a darkened room,
beads of sweat trickling down
their brows. The lights of
computer monitors shine up into their
faces. They’re tackling a monster that,
if it escapes, will literally devour all of
creation. It has no fear, it has no remorse,
and if it isn’t kept contained by Edna-84, it
may escape and wreak havoc across the world.
Oh, and did we mention it’s
trapped inside a Minecraft server?
You heard us right: SCP-4335 is a
cognitohazardous, extradimensional being
of pure terror, trapped inside a procedurally
generated world in the immensely popular game
Minecraft. You hear about a lot of horrifying
monsters being described as Lovecraftian, but only
this monster is Minecraftian. There’s a lot that
needs explaining here, and we intend to get to all
of it, but let’s start with how the Foundation
keeps this truly exceptional beast contained.
The Foundation first discovered SCP-4335 back
in 2010, shortly after the Alpha Version of
Minecraft was released. Because
of the online nature of the game,
it’s proven to be impossible to contain 4335
externally, seeing as it isn’t confined to
any one physical location. Shutting off the
server 4335 is found in is not an effective
containment method either, as this just causes
the entity to simply hop to a different server.
The Foundation’s greatest fear is that 4335
will one day make the leap out of Minecraft
and cause chaos in our world. That’s why it’s
imperative to draft Containment Procedures
for SCP-4335 within the game. This led to the
creation of a containment site unlike any other:
Site-M1, the first official Foundation Site made
entirely out of Minecraft blocks. Everyone who
was originally involved in the server has been
removed and amnesthetized. Since then, elite SCP
Foundation Containment Specialists and Gamers have
been constructing the perfect prison for SCP-4335.
Site-M1 is a large, stone complex built into
the side of a mountain. It has a number of key
features - including a supply area filled with
materials vital for 4335’s continued containment.
Chests filled with books that contain SCP-4335's
containment procedures. A few animal farms,
for the purpose of breeding and killing
livestock for their meat. The entrance to a
mine. Several chests containing books specifically
designed for civilians to learn about 4335,
if they ever breach containment and
enter the server. And of course,
the actual containment chamber for SCP-4335
itself, which is a little more complicated.
4335’s containment chamber is built out of
several layers, all made from iron blocks.
The outermost cube is 75 x 75 x 75 blocks,
the inner cube is 55 x 55 x 55 blocks,
and the innermost cube is 25 x 25 x 25 blocks,
creating several levels of defense. Finally
one layer within all these others, which contains
the anomaly proper, is made from obsidian blocks.
SCP-4335 is bound into the center
of the containment chamber with
a complex mechanism. The outermost
cube is completely filled with water,
and several dispensers capable of rapidly
dispensing large amounts of items in a
short amount of time line the cube. The
cube also contains several mob farms,
which are devices that constantly spawn enemies
into the chamber that drop loot when they die.
The chamber is essentially designed to funnel
a constant flow of items inwards to SCP-4335.
There are even contingency measures for if
SCP-4335 manages to breach containment. If
escape is attempted, blocks of TNT detonate
above the ceiling, causing lava to pour into
the chamber. At that point, MTF Edna-84 are
dispatched into the server to lure 4335 back
into its containment chamber. To do this, they
use a mix of fire-resistance potions and Ender
Pearls - which have teleportation capabilities.
Interestingly, there’s one more basic method of
luring SCP-4335 back into the obsidian cube:
Taunting and insulting. One of SCP-4335’s many
anomalous abilities is being able to hear
people through the screen, and - being a
proud creature - it often responds to insults
by charging in to directly engage the insulter.
If SCP-4335 still manages to breach the
containment that has been set up for it,
then they expect that it will likely soon
hop into another server. At that point,
the goal will shift to finding
the monster and recontaining it.
With Containment Procedures this complex and
extensive, it shouldn’t come as a surprise
that SCP-4335 rests firmly in the Keter Class.
What exactly is this anomalous entity? Why does
its containment hinge on constantly
providing it with items? And how did
it end up in Mojang’s popular building
and survival game in the first place?
SCP-4335, in terms of physical dimensions,
appears almost identical to the player character,
with an all-black skin. It also appears
to be constantly shrouded in a cloud of
smoke particles, and has long, black tendrils
protruding from its back. In some respects,
4335 has been compared to two
popular creepypasta figures:
Herobrine and The Slenderman. But 4335 is far
stranger. Its physical body behaves similarly
to most assets native to the game, with a few
peculiar anomalous abilities we’ll discuss soon.
Handling SCP-4335 is an extremely delicate
process. If command blocks, creative mode,
or server commands are ever enabled in a server
with SCP-4335, the server will instantly shut
down, and SCP-4335 will move to a different
server. SCP-4335 also uses its tendrils to
destroy surrounding blocks before consuming them.
With each successful consumption, SCP-4335 grows,
and when it reaches sufficient size, it hops to a
different server. As you can see, keeping SCP-4335
contained is an uphill battle, but luckily there
are two factors on the Foundation’s side here.
The first is that SCP-4335 is immobilized
while consuming items and blocks,
limiting its ability to actively escape
Foundation forces. The second factor is
that SCP-4335 needs a rest period between
consuming blocks in order to grow, meaning,
if its consumption is constant and continuous
it isn’t able to grow. These two factors have
informed the entirety of the Foundation’s
Containment Procedures around SCP-4335:
It’s locked into its chamber and
fed items and blocks constantly,
effectively rooting it in place. When SCP-4335
begins to grow, the Foundation also found that
the application of Ender Pearls helps
reduce it back to its normal size.
However, SCP-4335 does have a method of striking
back against its captors. 4335 is Vurgent-class
multi-sensory cognitohazard. Anyone viewing
it without proper training and protection may
experience distressing hallucinations. SCP-4335
is also capable of telepathic speech with people
playing on its server, and - as we alluded to
earlier - it can also hear any noises you make
while playing. “Weird” is a term thrown around a
lot when it comes to SCPs, considering it’s pretty
much a requirement for the Foundation to take
interest in you. But an all-devouring Minecraft
demon that can hear you talking through your
screen is strange even by Foundation standards.
MTF Edna-84 first discovered SCP-4335 in
the single-player server of Minecraft user
Leakingheart. Three team members
- Jason Yelsan, Richard Duchamp,
and Sheila Freemason - covertly entered the game
to investigate and potentially apprehend the
creature. When Leakingheart first discovered their
presence on what he thought was a private server,
he quickly left, a little creeped out
by the sudden intrusion. Thankfully,
the trio was still able to locate SCP-4335. They
discovered the creature hiding inside a giant
crater, as though it had impacted
the earth at considerable speed.
Richard Duchamp, who was the
leader of the team at the time,
made the mistake of looking directly at the
entity. In that moment, he experienced the
full force of SCP-4335’s cognitohazardous effects.
He hallucinated, believing that his keyboard was
melting before his eyes. In the aftermath of
this incident, Duchamp was taken off the case,
and Jason Yelsan was promoted to head of the
project. Things were still going to get stranger.
Yelsan was able to open a dialogue with the
creature after containing it in a chamber
filled with lava. It asked him whether it
had landed in the right location - meaning,
our world - and Yelsan informed it that it’d
somehow fallen into the world of Minecraft
instead. The creature was at first confused, and
then angry and resentful about its situation.
It vowed to find its way into our world
somehow, and obtain more “sustenance.”
A few months after this, the entity managed
to breach containment and hop into another
server. Yelsan and two others once again
managed to track it down and recontain it,
but this time, two civilians also
inhabiting the server were exposed
to the anomalous effects of SCP-4335. They
weren’t hurt, but they did appear strange
and incoherent after experiencing 4335’s
cognitohazards. The Foundation tracked
them down in the aftermath and gave them amnestic
treatment. 4335 was contained shortly thereafter.
Once again, Yelsan came face to face with his
new foe. Eight months after being captured,
4335 granted Yelsan another interview from
containment. 4335 admitted that it almost
respected Yelsan and the rest of the Foundation
for figuring out how to capture and contain it
so quickly. In exchange, it would give the
Foundation something extremely valuable:
Information. First, it asked one question
of Yelsan: How does he define “creation?”
Yelsan replied, “Uh… something that is
built and brought to this universe by
a sapient being, using other
things from this universe?”
4335 agreed. It went on to explain that it
came from a universe devoid of creation. A
dark and unknowable place, filled with nothing
but violent, random chaos. Its dimension existed
directly above ours, and it often looked
down at us through a dimensional window,
fascinated by all the creation below. It plotted
and dreamed to one day infiltrate our reality,
and Yelsan finally had the opportunity
to ask the magic question, “Why?”
Though he wasn’t quite ready for the
brutal honesty of SCP-4335’s reply.
“I do not like to lie, so I will tell you
now. I wish to suck it dry of the toys of
whatever force controls your universe.
Destroy the light, destroy the Earth,
and destroy humanity. It reminded me… of
me. A blubbering mass of intelligence and
order. It sickens me in ways I cannot
comprehend. I hope you understand.”
SCP-4335 was a connoisseur of creation, and
it sought to devour all of it. In this moment,
Yelsan realized what an incredibly dangerous
entity he was dealing with. The only mystery
was why this creature had somehow landed
in Minecraft instead of our world, which
appeared to be the only thing that saved us. But
Yelsan didn’t have time to think: 4335 was about
to stage another daring escape attempt. One of
its tendrils reached out and attacked Yelsan’s
player character. In that moment, the real
life Yelsan began to hallucinate and panic.
Suddenly, back in the game, a series of abnormally
tall, slender black figures appeared and began
deconstructing the containment chamber around
SCP-4335. It had somehow summoned new minions
into the game to assist in this containment
breach. Jason Yelsan entered cognitohazard
quarantine following this incident, and
was removed from the project. And he
wasn’t the only one affected by this incident.
Following the first appearance of these long,
dark figures, players across the globe began to
experience them appearing in their own games.
The Foundation managed to find a solution:
They contacted Mojang and had the creatures
patched into the game during the next
update, as a new non-anomalous entity,
which seemed to stop 4335 from being able
to use them as its own tools. They’re now
known as the Endermen, and are beloved among
fans for being one of the creepier enemies.
To this day, containment efforts continue
for SCP-4335. There’s only one question left:
Why did the entity fall into Minecraft
rather than our world? The file posits
the most likely answer. Because 4335 defines
creation as elements made by sapient beings.
In Minecraft, the most popular game in
the world at the height of 4335’s power,
everything that exists is the product of code
made by humans. Creation is truly abundant there.
As for our world, in SCP-4335’s extra-dimensional
eyes, there is no creation, no intelligent design,
no soothing piano soundtrack. Just
frightening, chaotic, randomness,
which is too unlike its own dimension. So even
if SCP-4335 ever did arrive in our reality,
it would likely be disappointed
by how little there is to eat.
The fabric of our world is littered with
strange doorways if you know where to look
for them. Tears, portals, anomalies, all
leading to places and planes beyond human
imagining and understanding, and SCP-2317,
otherwise known as A Door to Another World,
certainly fits that description. Contained and
kept at all times under the watch of armed guards,
SCP-2317 appears to be a simple and unsuspecting
wooden door in its frame. It hardly looks like it
requires such extreme round-the-clock security
or needs a strange, secretive ritual that the
Foundation performs, presumably to keep the
door closed. But, of course, sometimes the
most interesting thing about a closed doorway
isn’t where it leads, it’s what it keeps out.
Even by the Foundation’s already-high standards,
the requirements and regulations for personnel
who are assigned to SCP-2317 seem oddly specific.
Psychological testing is standard practice for to
work for the Foundation, but an additional
hurdle that anyone has to clear before even
getting to glimpse at this unassuming wooden
door is having a score of at least seventy-two
on the Milgram Obedience Examination. It is also
mandatory that personnel assigned to maintaining
it are both unmarried, with no children
or next-of-kin, as well as an unwavering,
unquestioning loyalty to the Foundation,
pure devotion to its code and objectives.
These may seem like strange requirements,
after all, SCP-2317 is just a door…isn’t it?
Perhaps there’s a reason that the Foundation
keeps so much of the information about SCP-2317
buried deep under layers upon layers of security,
with only the Overseer Council privy to the full
details of its strange nature. Knowledge, as they
say, is power - but maybe knowing too much about
whatever is behind that door can prove deadly.
Still, if SCP-2317 is a Door to Another World,
an alternate dimension or parallel reality,
it must be safe enough to visit. After all,
the Foundation has been sending personnel
in there on a regular basis. Daily, in fact.
According to the O5 Council, this is done as part
of a procedure to maintain Active Containment
of…something lurking beyond
that old wooden doorframe.
But what could possibly warrant such
constant maintenance and surveillance?
In accordance with the Foundation’s guidelines,
all staff are required to rotate out of observing
SCP-2317 after every two months and spend the
following third month in full psychological
counselling before they are permitted to
return to the containment unit housing the
Door to Another World. It was after one of
these month-long periods of evaluation that
a Foundation guard was informed that his security
clearance had been raised to Level 3 and that he’d
been selected for the duty of carrying out
220-Calabasas. He knew the name instantly;
this was the title given to the daily containment
procedure that absolutely had to be carried out.
The guard didn’t question these orders, after
all, he’d been selected precisely because of
his loyalty to the Foundation. He did make one
request to his commanding officer, however:
he wanted to know what had happened to the
last guard that had performed the procedure.
“Didn’t make it out of psychological
evaluation,” the officer replied.
Not letting this affect his dedication, the guard
was told to prepare for Procedure 220-Calabasas.
Along with a fellow member of Foundation security
personnel, the guard was instructed to gather
everything on a strange list. The first was
a pre-selected member of Class-D Personnel,
specifically a convicted murderer. Class-D
refers to ‘Disposable Class’ personnel,
expendable individuals recruited by the
Foundation for the sole purpose of testing SCPs.
Class-Ds were usually prison inmates
repurposed for SCP testing, and the
one chosen for 220-Calabasas was no exception,
serving multiple life sentences for murders,
or at least that was what the guard
had been told. A Foundation personnel
member instructed him to refer to the Class-D
solely as the ‘assistant’ from that point on.
Next, the guard collected a live
chicken, an obsidian-edged knife,
a silver aspergillum and aspersorium, to be
filled with 500ccs of Holy Water that had
been blessed by a priest of the Abrahamic faith,
and finally a one-kiloton nuclear device, which,
according to instructions, was to only
be detonated in the unlikely event of a
catastrophic containment failure.
In other words, the last resort.
After following his instructions to the letter and
without question, the guard and his colleague were
briefed. The Foundation personnel member informed
them that he’d be joining and leading them in the
procedure. The staff member also specified that
henceforth he be referred to as the ‘celebrant’
until the completion of 220-Calabasas. The
guard was acutely aware of how specific these
instructions were, but trusted in the Foundation,
knowing that if they wanted this procedure
performed a certain way, then it was in everyones’
best interest to carry out the orders to the
letter. But what the celebrant then went on to
explain, raised far more questions about SCP-2317
and the nature of Procedure 220-Calabasas. The
Class-D joining them, wasn’t actually a Class-D.
The assistant, as they were now referred to,
was in reality another Foundation staff member,
with a Level 4 security clearance,
specifically tailored to SCP-2317.
Every member of staff entering through SCP-2317
and taking an active role in 220-Calabasas needed
to be informed that this assistant was not to be
harmed or treated as a member of Disposable Class.
Fighting back the nagging question of why
the Foundation would employ this subterfuge,
the guard, along with his fellow security
officer, the celebrant and assistant,
prepared for their departure through
the Door to Another World at solar noon,
when the sun was highest over SCP-2317.
Solar noon, chickens and holy water,
this all seemed like an oddly-occult
combination for the Foundation.
As they entered the old wooden door, beyond
lay a barren salt plane, stretching out for
kilometers in every direction. This alternate
dimension, according to the briefing,
was designated SCP-2317-Prime. The guard
immediately noticed a ring of seven pillars
directly ahead of the group as they entered, each
of them bearing intricately-detailed engravings
unlike anything from any era of ancient history.
Procedure 220-Calabasas was carried out quickly,
but carefully, the guard watching as the celebrant
and assistant were careful not to miss a step.
First, the celebrant scattered Holy Water
into the center of the pillars with the
aspergillum and aspersorium, looking down
at his feet and keeping a steady pace as he
stepped counter-clockwise around them. The guard
watched intently as the celebrant completed his
circuit around the pillars and turned to the
assistant, anointing his head with Holy Water.
“Seven Seals, Seven Rings, Seven Thrones
for the Scarlet King,” he said aloud.
The assistant, with the obsidian blade in
his hand, took the chicken and dispatched it
in sacrifice, letting its blood mix with the
Holy Water. He then repeated the celebrant’s
circuit in the opposite direction, before
stepping into the center of the stone pillars.
“Blood for the Old Gods, Water for the New King,”
the assistant recited, pouring the remaining mix
of blood and Holy Water over a patch of
salt in the middle of the seven pillars.
Even though he knew it wasn’t his place to
question the Foundation, as the 220-Calabasas
procedure took place, the guard couldn’t
help but wonder what all this was for.
It seemed so…ritualistic, like something
deeply religious or even magical. He’d never
bought into all that occult mumbo-jumbo,
even while working for the Foundation,
but he had learned not to question anything, even
the strangest and most inexplicable of sights.
Little did he know that beneath his feet, was an
ancient and unknowable horror. A beast, chained
and lying in wait. Contained in a chamber directly
underneath the pillars, sat an impossibly-large
creature. Humanoid and obese, its body covered
entirely in scales thicker than armour plating.
Branch-like horns protruded from its jawless
head, pointing up to chains that hung from the
seven pillars above, each one hooked into the
entity’s back. All but one of the chains was
broken, a final, withering shackle keeping the
Devourer of Worlds in its underground prison.
Ever since 1894 BCE, when Erikeshan mystics
imprisoned it, the Devourer has been waiting
patiently for its inevitable freedom. It knows,
as well as the Foundation, that nothing can be
done to prevent the final chain from one day
breaking. Even Procedure 220-Calabasas won’t
keep the creature contained, it’s nothing more
than a smokescreen, an act, designed to create
an illusion of active containment and maintain
Foundation morale until a permanent solution
can be devised to keep SCP-2317 imprisoned.
Of course, if the guard had known this, it would
have also explained the need for a one-kiloton
nuclear device as part of this staged ritual.
Procedure 220-Calabasas has all the components
to trick everyone below the O5 Council,
emulating religious and occult rituals, the
increased level of security surrounding the
procedure and its purpose, and telling staff
that any failure to correctly, and completely,
perform the 220-Calabasas procedure will result
in an XK-Class End of the World Scenario.
All these elements work together to conceal
the truth: that one day, the Devourer will
escape and lay waste to our dimension.
Knowledge is power, and maybe knowing
too much truly is deadly. Perhaps if the guard
had learned any of this, he’d have understood
why his predecessor never made it out of
psychological evaluation. Maybe if he had
questioned the purpose of Procedure 220-Calabasas,
he'd have learned the true nature of SCP-2317,
and what that doorway kept out. But he was
loyal to the Foundation, through and through.
As the team finished performing 220-Calabasas
and returned though the wooden door, the guard
took one last glance over his shoulder at the vast
salt plane. The entire dimension was calm, silent,
but not peaceful: it was patient. The
entity had waited centuries for its time,
and now all it would take was the breaking
of the seventh and final chain. One day.
The door was closed behind the guard as he,
the celebrant, the assistant and his fellow
security officer stepped back through,
their work done and, as far as they knew,
preventing catastrophe for another day.
Only the Foundation higher-ups, the Overseer
Council, are aware of the true danger posed
by SCP-2317 and its sole inhabitant. Current
predictions are that at some point within the
next thirty years, the Devourer of Worlds will
be freed. Any and all attempts to repair or
recreate the chains holding it in place have so
far failed. As such, the O5 Council has elected
to continue providing Foundation personnel with
the ignorant hope that Procedure 220-Calabasas
is an effective strategy for containment.
As we’ve said, sometimes the most interesting
thing about a closed door isn’t where it leads,
it’s what it keeps out. In the case of SCP-2317,
the unassuming wooden door holds at bay
an ancient creature of untold power,
that will one day break free and wreak havoc in
our dimension. Nothing the Foundation does can
prevent it, or keep it contained behind the
Door to Another World, and only the Overseer
Council knows that any and all efforts to
do so are futile. With all that in mind,
we can only hope that the doorway of SCP-2317
stays closed, at least for a little while longer.
It was November 20th, 2019, and the helicopter
circled far above in the freezing wind of the
Antarctic. SCP Foundation Site Director
Jason Monroe looked down at the isolated
above-ground facilities of Provisional
Site-344-1. Something about this place
made him nervous. Edgy. And for good reason:
Between 2003 and 2019, twenty-nine Mobile
Task Force units and seventy-three members
of D-Class personnel had gone missing here
and never been found. Monroe thought he
was here for a routine investigation into
negligence and mismanagement, but little
did he know, he was in for so much more.
This is the story of SCP - 5545, and one man’s
journey into his own worst nightmare. Literally.
But this nightmare began a long time ago - 300
years, to be exact. And like most nightmares,
it started as a dream. That dream was one
of expansion - national powers across Europe
wanted to be the first to conquer the
globe and expand into new territories,
and sent countless exploratory missions off into
the unknown to achieve this goal. Any history
book will tell you that the first outsiders to
lay eyes upon the continent of Antarctica did
so in 1820 - the reality is that the first ones
to get there actually landed in the late 1700s.
The hapless explorers ventured into
mainland Antarctica and made base camps,
before searching and digging for any
useful resources nearby. They came
upon a strange discovery: A hallway, hidden
beneath the ice. Not a passage in the ice,
but a true hallway - complete with light
fixtures. The confused explorers ventured
down into these impossible hallways, and for many
of them, it would be the last thing they ever did.
No matter how long they walked, it seemed like
the hallways just kept going. As they continued to
walk for hours, they hoped they’d find something…
anything. And eventually, they did. They passed
from these hallways into somewhere different
altogether, and most of them were never heard
from again. Those who did manage to escape often
died or took their own lives soon after. Whatever
it was they’d discovered down there, they
didn’t want to live with it on their minds.
It’s believed that over seventy colonial explorers
disappeared or died this way and that most who
found these endless hallways beneath the Antarctic
ice never returned. The multiple anomalous objects
and phenomena that make up SCP-5545 came into
the Foundation’s hands several centuries later
on September 8th, 2003, when during an
expedition into the Antarctic, they too
found the endless hallways. The Foundation
built Provisional Site-344-1 around them,
hoping to safely seal them off from any other
unwitting Antarctic explorers or researchers.
But there was something else lurking beneath
the ice in Antarctica. Something dangerous. The
hallways were designated as SCP - 5545 - 1 and
were thought to be the extent of the anomalous
activity at the site, but soon SCP - 5455 - 2
was discovered, which resulted in the deaths of
sixteen researchers. So what exactly is 5545 - 2?
It’s an entity so volatile that even knowing about
it is considered to be a containment breach, and -
as a result - it’s kept in Provisional Site-344-2.
Unlike Site - 344 - 1, 344 - 2 isn’t a physical
space. It’s conceptual, accessible only through
the endless hallways, created with the express
purpose of keeping 5545 - 1 and 5545 - 2 separate.
Why? Because whenever the two come
into contact, the result is 5545 - 3:
The network of endless hallways expanding. If
they remained in contact, the hallways would
continue to expand and the entire planet
could be filled with endless hallways in
just four to six hours. While the two
are apart though, 5545 - 3 reverses,
but it always would take just a few hours to throw
the whole world into a chaos of infinite hallways.
SCP-5455 has been given the classification
“Safe”… Wait, we’re dealing with a mysterious
and volatile anomaly that’s claimed a huge number
of lives and still somehow eludes true Foundation
understanding, yet the official SCP Foundation
classification is “Safe?” How could this be?
This same thought process brings us to 2018,
when Jason Monroe first took interest in SCP
- 5545. Monroe was the Director of Site -
58, and was the definition of no-nonsense.
Prior to taking the Site Director position,
he was a decorated member of Mobile Task
Force Eta-10 and helped contain numerous
Keter-Class anomalies. He’d been around the
proverbial block when it came to anomalous
activity, and something about SCP - 5545,
and the management of Provisional Site 344, seemed
awfully suspicious to him. And he had questions.
Like how such an unpredictable anomaly could be
declared “safe”? And why had there been such a
lapse of communication between the Foundation
and Doctor Gabriel Reed, who’d been running the
facility for the past two decades? And most
of all, just what exactly was the mysterious
SCP - 5545 - 2? Monroe started to believe that
something terrible had happened at the site,
and Reed was covering it all up. But to find
out for sure, he’d need to go to Antarctica
and investigate it himself. Information
around this supposedly “Safe” anomaly was
highly classified - those without O5 clearance
could face termination for snooping. But that
didn’t scare Jason Monroe. He’d dealt with Keters
before, he could deal with this. Or so he thought.
Monroe submitted a request and was granted
unanimous approval by the O5 Council to
travel to Provisional Site 344 and get
to the bottom of this mystery. He took
a chopper to the base soon after, armed
with a concealed firearm and a Hostile
Meme Detector - or HMD - to test whether
the base and its staff had somehow fallen
under a hazardous memetic effect from SCP -
5545. He’d find the answers, or die trying.
The moment Monroe arrived, he couldn’t help but
notice the strange way the staff behaved. They
seemed listless; almost depressive. When
he showed his credentials to a researcher,
they simply said “SCP-5545-2 is contained
in Site-344-2.” His request to see Dr.
Reed that night was denied. Dr. Reed was
busy, he was told. Wait until tomorrow.
The next day, Monroe met with Dr.
Reed, but the results of the meeting
were underwhelming to say the least. Just
like the rest of the staff on the site,
he seemed exhausted, as though he hadn’t slept
in days. His responses were quiet and evasive,
and he refused to tell Monroe anything
that wasn’t in the official files already.
Monroe ran the conversation through the HMD and
found nothing out of the ordinary. What was going
on here? Monroe was irritated, but not deterred.
Nothing would stop him from finding out the truth.
The next day, he flexed his O5 credentials
and hacked into the base’s security system.
This gave him access to cameras around
Site - 344 -1, but more importantly,
there was a single camera inside the mysterious
Site - 344 - 2. Jackpot. But when he looked at it,
the feed was an entirely black screen with the
words “SCP-5545-2 is contained in Site-344-2.”
The footage of the staff in 344 - 1 was equally
strange: The eighteen employees on site all sat at
computer banks, with nothing but static playing
on their screens. Monroe kept digging though,
and was able to hack into the security
footage of Dr. Reed’s office. As he watched,
he discovered a fifteen minute period
where Reed left the office each day.
He could use this brief window to break in
and collect more intel on SCP - 5545 - 2.
Monroe was so wrapped up in the investigation
that he almost forgot the more immediate danger
around him, and nearly wandered
into one of the endless hallways
of 5545 - 1 by mistake. He made a
note to be more careful in future...
His first attempt at breaking into Dr. Reed’s
office didn’t produce many answers - one piece
of evidence was a blurry picture of what looked
like a Mobile Task Force entering a 5545 - 1
hallway in the dark. Another was a spreadsheet
featuring all the personnel, living or dead,
who’d worked at the site - but one name, and the
details of whether this person was alive or dead,
was completely redacted. Anything
particularly juicy was hidden behind
O5 clearance. If Monroe wanted the
answers, he’d need to break through.
That night, he had a horrific recurring
nightmare, one that had plagued him since
he joined MTF Eta-10. He dreamed he was in a
fancy dining room with a grand fireplace. The
room was full of statues of men and women. The men
looked angry, and the women looked afraid. As he
approached the fireplace, the ceiling extended
infinitely up into the darkness. Suddenly,
the zombie-like body of a teenage girl appears
in the fireplace, hanging from a long thread.
Her eyes look furious and full of rage, and Monroe
somehow knows that he’s the reason for her hate.
When he steps into the fireplace in this
dream, she attacks him, the two intertwine,
and they burn forever. The one difference
was that in this new iteration of the dream,
he blinked upon entering the fireplace,
and suddenly, he was in a hallway. He
awoke sure that something was terribly
wrong here, but he couldn’t give up now.
The next day, Monroe broke into Dr. Reed’s office
and made a horrifying discovery. He found files
indicating that Dr. Reed was knowingly sending
Mobile Task Forces and D-Class personnel into the
infinite hallways of 5545 - 1 to their doom. He
also found evidence that Reed and the researchers
had been spying on him, somehow intercepting
copies of the notes he had been taking.
That’s when Dr. Reed entered the office and
interrupted him. Monroe panicked and drew
his weapon, holding the doctor at gunpoint.
He was breaking so many Foundation rules,
but right now, he feared for his life. The
doctor seemed unbothered by Monroe’s threats
though. He told Monroe that everything was going
to plan, and that he should go back to his room.
Monroe was becoming increasingly paranoid - he
felt that, at any moment, guards might burst
in and execute him. Nothing about this place made
sense. He worried he was going insane. Perhaps the
only way to find answers was to go even deeper:
To risk it all, and venture through the endless
hallways to find SCP - 5545 - 2 himself, and
finally discover what this thing actually was.
Monroe left his room and stepped into one of the
endless hallways of 5545 - 1 that was located
just across from his dorm. Hefound that it was
a hallway like all the others on site - Plain
concrete, worn with age, with simple light
fixtures on the walls. He walked for hours,
recording with a concealed device. The
lights suddenly went out, leaving him
in complete darkness. When they flicked back
on, he was in a very different environment:
A grand, old carpeted hallway, the
kind you’d see in an old mansion.
He broke into a cold sweat. What
was so familiar about this place?
He kept walking, wracked with terror, until
this new hallway finally led him to the place
he’d been seeking: Site 344 - 2, the domain
of 5545 - 2. It was a large, poorly-lit room,
filled with grimacing statues and a large
fireplace at the far end. It was the exact same
room from Monroe’s dream - with one horrifying
difference. Monroe noticed a single white thread
hanging down from the infinite ceiling, and when
he looked up to find its source, he screamed.
There were hundreds of bodies hanging
and swinging from the ceiling above
him - everyone who SCP - 5545 - 2 had ever
killed, including MTF members, D-Class Personnel,
and even the colonial explorers from hundreds
of years before. And all of them were him.
Every single one. They had his face. And there,
hanging in the middle of the room at ground level,
was the body of a teenage girl, the
one from his dream. In that moment,
he finally recognized her: She was the girl he
killed. The first him. Hundreds of years ago.
Much like Monroe, you’re probably wondering:
What is going on here? Thanks to declassified
communications between Dr. Reed and the O5
Council, we can tell you. Jason Monroe is
a man who’s been reincarnated hundreds of
times over the last three hundred years,
ever since he murdered a teenage girl…
A girl named Emily… his daughter.
This murder sparked the existence of SCP -
5545 as an eternally recurring punishment
for his crimes. Since figuring this out,
the Foundation has kept tabs on Monroe’s
reincarnations - whether they’re MTF members,
D-Class personnel, or even Site Directors.
They see to it that these reincarnations
always find their way back to 5545 - 2
to take his punishment, and prevent the
infinite hallway expansion that threatens
to destroy the world. It’s a plan everyone is
in on - everyone except him. But every time
he enters that nightmare-haunting
room, it all comes rushing back.
In that moment though, he knew his crime, and he
somehow knew how many times this punishment had
unfolded for him. He now had two choices: Repent
and accept the punishment again, or leave and
activate 5545 - 3, potentially allowing the
endless tunnels to expand across the world.
Like his many predecessors, Monroe made the decent
choice. He accepted his punishment and allowed his
own string to coil around him as the lights in the
room went off, one by one, leaving only darkness.
Jason Monroe - that version of him,
at least - was never seen again.
But The SCP Foundation is already
eyeing up his next reincarnation,
and preparing to let this twisted
cycle play out all over again.
If that story had you on the edge of your
seat, then why not subscribe to SCP Explained
and hit the bell for notifications! You
can find out how humanity almost pushed
Bigfoot to extinction, discover why you
should never look at the Shy Guy’s face,
and see the terrifying things the SCP
Foundation are up to in alternate realities!
Are you sitting comfortably?
We know a good chair is hard to
find. Maybe you’re watching this
on your phone while you lie in bed, or
maybe you’re watching it at your desk,
sitting in an office chair. Maybe you’re even
watching it while you’re in the bathroom; it’s
fine, we’re not here to judge. For our money, you
just can’t beat a nice, classic wooden chair, with
soft leather upholstery. Call us old-fashioned,
but some things just never go out of style.
Take a chair like SCP-1609, for example.
This fine piece of mahogany was once a chair that
simply couldn’t be beat in its quest to bring its
users a little dose of comfort and refinement in
their daily life. Tell us, have you ever been on
your feet all day, just walking and walking
and walking, and at a certain point, you’re
just begging for a nice, comfy chair that’ll let
you take the weight off your feet for a little
while? You would have been SCP-1609’s favorite
kind of person. After all, it was the only chair
that literally sought out weary travelers, and
even did you the courtesy of tucking itself in.
That’s not a metaphor, either. SCP-1609
could literally teleport to nearby people
who needed to sit down and didn’t have a chair to
fulfill that desire. It was nothing but a nice,
helpful anomaly that wanted to help
people rest when they needed it most.
The more observant members of you may have
noticed that we’ve been using the past tense
so far. That’s because, while SCP-1609
is still an active anomaly, it isn’t a
chair anymore - and this transformation
wasn’t something that SCP-1609 planned,
anticipated, or even wanted. The story of
1609’s transformation even strikes to the
core of one of the Foundation’s oldest and most
bitterly held rivalries with another group of
interest. It’s the tale of how a helpful piece
of anomalous furniture became a paranoid killer.
But first, we need to talk
about containment procedures.
Like a word you see so often
that it starts to lose meaning,
containment and specific containment procedures
are concepts so integral to the very existence
of the SCP Foundation that it’s easy to
overlook or forget about them. They’re one
of the three core pillars of the Foundation’s
mission statement - Secure, Contain, Protect.
Because of the centrality of containment
to the Foundation’s core principles,
one of the most valuable roles on the SCP
Foundation payroll is that of the Containment
Specialist: A vast team of experts who work with
researchers to figure out the best way to keep
every anomaly contained, based on their unique
abilities and attributes. They’re zookeepers,
archivists, guards, security and intelligence
experts, magicians, practitioners of ritual,
scientists, and so much more. In short,
they’re anything they need to be in order
to adapt to the ever-evolving containment needs
of the anomalies they keep under lock and key.
And containment isn’t easy. Aside from the rare
Safe-class SCPs, which require incredibly minimal
containment resources, the containment
of most SCPs extracts some kind of cost,
whether that be financial, time, effort, or
in some particularly dark cases, human life.
Some SCPs, like SCP-974 and SCP-2845, require
the sacrifice of human children to prevent
worse fates befalling many others.
Other SCPs, like the infamous SCP-231,
require the Foundation to do horrifying things
to the SCP itself to prevent it from manifesting
some even more horrifying anomalous traits. And
a third but equally inconvenient kind of SCP,
like SCP-682 and SCP-076, require huge numbers
of heavily armed guards with powerful weapons
to keep their deadly prisoners locked away,
often at massive risk to their own lives.
Containment isn’t easy, but it’s ultimately
the very thing that makes the SCP Foundation
the organization it is. If they were instead
on a quest to kill and destroy every anomaly
they could get their hands on, then, they’d
be the Global Occult Coalition - the UN’s
answer to the SCP Foundation that prefers to seek,
disable, and destroy rather than Secure, Contain,
and Protect. It’s the primary characteristic that
differentiates these two titans of the anomalous
world who regularly come to blows, and right
at the heart of that difference is SCP-1609.
As we mentioned earlier, SCP-1609 went through
a transformation that changed everything,
but the SCP Foundation never actually knew about
the anomaly prior to that transformation taking
place. It first came to their attention
when it literally manifested within a
containment cell in Storage Site-08, making
the rare move of willingly submitting itself
to Foundation containment. But what showed
up in that cell certainly wasn’t a chair.
When 1609 appeared all it looked like was
a pile of trash - specifically, splinters,
wood chippings, furniture nails, and
scraps of bleached leather and fabric.
Anything that suddenly infiltrates a secure
Foundation containment site is a cause for
concern, even a bunch of wood scraps, so the Site
Director sent in an armed guard to investigate
the mysterious pile of debris. Researchers
watching over a surveillance feed were surprised
when the guard suddenly entered a state of
heightened distress. He fell to his knees,
coughing and spluttering until he expelled
a considerable amount of blood from his
mouth and nose. He then collapsed onto the
ground next to the pile of debris, dead.
An investigation following this incident found
that the guard had died after a sudden influx
of jagged metal and wood had teleported
inside of him, tearing his lungs apart
from the inside and causing the guard
to die a painful and horrific death.
Naturally, the site personnel were somewhat
concerned by this development. They sent in
a D-Class to investigate further, but
were surprised to find that the D-Class
in question was somehow completely fine. The
pile of debris that would soon be designated
SCP-1609 made no attempt to harm the D-Class as
it had the guard, and finding out why this was
the case came as a side effect of figuring
out exactly what had happened to SCP-1609.
Through a rigorous investigation, involving
more than one secret Foundation mole,
they discovered that SCP-1609 had previously been
in the possession of - you guessed it - the Global
Occult Coalition. Back then, it was just
the helpful chair you once knew and loved,
until the GOC had the bright idea of forcing
it into a woodchipper in order to destroy it
due to its connection to someone called The
Carpenter. But all the GOC’s attempt actually
succeeded in doing was altering its form,
and completely changing its personality.
To put it in simple terms, SCP-1609 is now a pile
of possibly-sentient, teleporting wood and metal
chippings that suffers from a nasty case of PTSD.
The incident with the wood chipper traumatized
SCP-1609, and its anxiety is triggered by
anything that reminds it of the GOC or the
wood chipper incident - this includes wearing
formal clothing, lab coats, protective clothing,
jumpsuits, and particularly body armor, but
also includes anyone carrying weapons, appearing
outwardly aggressive, using common GOC lingo, or
even mentioning the GOC in SCP-1609’s proximity.
If any of this happens, it’s extremely likely
that SCP-1609 will resort to its only natural
defense mechanism, which is teleporting its
debris into the lungs of anyone it considers
to be a threat. The guard had received this
grisly punishment because his clothes, weapon,
and overall manner caused SCP-1609 to regard
him as a threat and react accordingly. You may
think this is overkill on 1609’s part, but if you
were just trying to help out the chairless people
of the world and someone fed you into a wood
chipper, you’d probably be a little jumpy too.
Since these early days, the Foundation has
learned to apply a more tender touch when it
comes to dealing with SCP-1609, and the brilliant
containment specialists even figured out a way
to keep 1609 happily contained… by placing
it in a flower bed inside its containment
chamber where its wood chips get to serve as
mulch for a variety of flowers and plants.
All attending researchers and
guards dress in plain clothes,
and adopt a loose, pleasant attitude
while inside. Whenever they’re around,
they make a point of saying how beautiful
the flower bed is, so that the disfigured
anomaly that only ever wanted to be helpful
can still feel like it’s doing something nice.
Because of these containment procedures,
breaches involving SCP-1609 have remained in
the single digits. It’s a perfect example of less
really being more when it comes to containment.
The head researcher on the SCP-1609 case,
Dr. Sievert, released an internal document,
permanently affixed to the file like a kind of
cautionary signpost. It’s a clear expression
of exasperation and rage at the actions
of the Global Occult Coalition, reading:
“SCP-1609 represents a perfect example of the
flaws inherent in the operating procedure of
the GOC, and serves as a cautionary tale for
any members of the Foundation who disagree with
our practices on containing dangerous objects.
Prior to the Coalition getting their hands on
this, it was perfectly harmless. A chair which
teleports to you when you need a seat is normal
compared to most of the stuff that we deal with
on a regular basis. When they put it through a
woodchipper, it got hurt, scared and angry, so
it lashed out at them. By trying to 'protect
the world' by destroying it, they inadvertently
made the situation a whole lot worse. SCP-1609
went from being harmless to deadly in the
space of a few minutes because of the GOC,
and we had to clean up the mess.
Thankfully, SCP-1609 is pretty simple
for us to deal with. So long as we don't do
anything stupid around it, it won't fight back
and it won't try to leave. Even if it does,
it usually comes back. I think I've worked
out why. It came to us because it was afraid
of the people who had hurt it. That's why it
always comes back. It's afraid of the rest of the
world now, and it's looking to us for protection.
This is why we have Special Containment
Procedures instead of Special Destruction
Procedures. If you break something, it's broken
forever. When you try to destroy an anomaly,
you can't take back your mistakes. That's
what SCP-1609 has to tell us. This is why
we're right and the GOC is wrong, people.”
But of course, there are two sides to every
story, and it’s important to understand the GOC’s
perspective on this whole mess. To them, this has
never been SCP-1609, it’s KTE-0937-Velveteen,
aka The Sixth Chair. It was labeled as the
“sixth” because for the GOC, this chair was
merely one part of a wider investigation.
It belonged to a six piece furniture set
created by a dangerous, anomalous person
of interest named The Carpenter for a classified
customer. The GOC was able to intercept this deal,
and kill the Carpenter and his customer in
the process. After that, all that was left
was to eliminate the anomalous objects and five of
them were incinerated without incident. However,
before they could do the same to the Sixth Chair,
they experienced an incinerator malfunction.
Rather than waiting for the incinerator to be
fixed, a member of GOC personnel decided to
rush the job and run the chair through the
woodchipper. It was at this point that its
pieces first lashed out, invading the lungs of
this negligent GOC member along with five others,
killing them all. It was shortly after that that
SCP-1609 manifested in Foundation containment.
Much like Dr. Sievert did for the Foundation,
Assistant Director Kipling, one of the GOC’s
legion of middle managers, affixed a note to
the profile on KTE-0937-Velveteen that reads:
“KTE-0937-Velveteen is an object lesson in
the importance of following proper operating
procedures. Due to the lack of vigilance by
the agent on the scene, the object's threat
level was escalated, the object itself
was not successfully disposed of, and it
has since fallen into the hands of a hostile
agency. A single failure by a single operative
resulted in the deaths of six. Remember this
the next time you think about cutting corners.”
And that’s a good lesson for everyone. Whether
you’re trying to destroy an anomalous piece of
furniture or keeping its remains happy
so that they don’t try to kill you,
cutting corners is always a fast track to failure.
Joseph and Frank were two life-long Squatchers.
No, that isn’t an insult – that’s a self-given
title for Bigfoot enthusiasts who are willing
to head out into the woods and search for the
legendary Sasquatch first-hand. While most
Squatchers will go their whole lives without
ever encountering one, Joseph and Frank were about
to get lucky – they just didn’t know what kind of
luck. During a journey through the forests of
the Pacific Northwest, Frank spotted something
moving in the distance: A huge, ape-like creature
with greyish fur and human-like movements. Frank
thought he was finally laying eyes on the
mighty Bigfoot after decades of searching.
What he didn’t know was that he’d just made a
deadly mistake. He had looked directly at SCP –
1000. And there would be terrible consequences.
Frank was excited – he’d just achieved the life
goal of any Squatcher. He tapped Joseph on
the shoulder and directed him to look in the
direction of the creature. Joseph followed Frank’s
direction and stared into the distance. When
his eyes finally came into focus on the ape-like
beast... he froze. His brain just short-circuited.
One second, he was about to encounter the
Holy Grail of his hobby, and the next,
he was literally brain dead. Joseph collapsed.
In the distance, the ape-like creature
disappeared back into the woods. Not
that Frank even noticed – he was too
busy trying to wake Joseph but it was no use.
Joseph was gone, and Frank had no idea why.
The headlines read, “BIGFOOT KILLED MY FRIEND.”
Most people either ignored it or laughed it off.
Just a couple of cranks goofing off in a forest
and one of them had dropped dead. Who cares? Well,
one organization cared – The SCP Foundation.
Mobile Task Force Zeta-1000, the Foundation’s
specialized SCP – 1000 detail, were alerted
to the reports. They sprang into action,
tracking down and detaining Frank for questioning.
They process a million loony bigfoot lovers every
year, and usually find nothing, but the
death of Frank’s friend made it all too
clear – they hadn’t encountered a bigfoot
but a real, genuine example of SCP – 1000.
SCP – 1000 rarely ranks among the scariest or most
dangerous SCPs, but underestimating the creature
is a terrible mistake because just looking at
it gives you a 2% chance of dropping dead on
the spot. Frank, despite losing his friend,
was one of the lucky ones. The Foundation
debriefed him before administering amnestics,
and making sure that he’d never venture back to
those mysterious forests in the Pacific Northwest
again. Director Jones, the site director charged
with the management of SCP – 1000 populations,
was given the information on this latest case
of a SCP – 1000-related fatality. It was a story
he’d heard many times before. For Director Jones,
they all seemed to bleed into one another.
So, what exactly is SCP – 1000? And how did
it leave poor Joseph dead in the woods?
SCP – 1000 is a whole species of large,
hominid ape-like creatures. They’re largely
nocturnal, but sightings of the creature
during the day aren’t unheard of. They’re
omnivorous, mostly seeming to consume plants
and insects and their fur is usually grey,
brown, black, red, or occasionally white.
The creatures have large eyes capable of
impressive vision nestled underneath a pronounced,
Neanderthal-like brow. Another defining
feature is the ridge of bone on the forehead,
much like that of a gorilla, that is present
in both sexes. According to Foundation studies,
the creatures exhibit a level of intelligence
on par with that of the common chimpanzee,
but nowhere near that of us humans. What they lack
in intelligence, though, they more than make up
for in size. The adults can be as large as
ten feet tall, and weigh up to 600 pounds.
Despite their great size and impressive
strength, the creatures are neither
aggressive nor territorial. In fact, they
seem to instinctively avoid humans, mostly
residing deep in the forests of the American
Pacific Northwest and in the Himalayan Alps.
There have been sightings of SCP – 1000 on every
continent, though the Foundation has taken pains
to exterminate all SCP – 1000 populations
situated near human population centres to
prevent a potential disaster, considering the 2%
chance of instantaneous death upon visual contact.
That brings us to our second question: What is
it that makes these seemingly harmless creatures
so dangerous? Sadly, for both these unfortunate
creatures and us humans, the danger is beyond the
control of SCP – 1000. According to Foundation
research, SCP – 1000 likely evolved alongside
us homo sapiens, until a tragedy occurred
between ten and fifteen-thousand years ago.
A mysterious extinction event eliminated the
vast majority of their species, leaving only
one to five percent alive in the aftermath. What
happened? It’s believed that around this time,
SCP – 1000 contracted what the Foundation
refers to as an “anomalous pseudo-disease.”
Meet SCP-1000-f1, a disease that is passed along
at the genetic level, and is so durable that it
persists in the species to this day. The tiny
fraction of the population that are immune to
its effects manage to survive, but the majority
who aren’t immune die shortly after birth. This
is why the overall population remains relatively
low to this day. It’s a disease that only
appears to affect hominids – including humans,
chimpanzees, bonobos, and non-immune instances
of SCP-1000. Any hominid that lays eyes on
a carrier of the disease has a two percent
chance of experiencing immediate brain death.
While a two percent chance of instant death
may not seem all that threatening, at least when
compared to some other nightmare inducing SCPs,
the truly scary part is that the percentage
is cumulative. In other words, the longer
one observes a carrier of SCP-1000-f1, the higher
that percentage rises and the greater your chance
of experiencing an abrupt death. According
to Foundation studies, the percentage rises
by around one percent every twenty minutes. And
the percentage also varies between specimens,
with some exhibiting a terrifyingly high death
chance of 90% upon viewing. This death chance
continues to occur in dead specimens if
they carried the anomalous pseudo-virus
while alive – though thankfully the risk doesn’t
appear to apply to small fur or tissue samples.
The Foundation’s true concern actually goes far
beyond SCP – 1000 themselves. Because of the
species’ close relation to homo sapiens, there’s
a worry that SCP-1000-f1 could transmit to humans,
causing our own species to meet a similar fate. If
humans did indeed become carriers of SCP-1000-f1,
it’s extremely likely that humanity would
undergo an unprecedented extinction event,
with billions across the globe dropping
dead as brain death sets in en masse. While
full extermination of the entire species has
been deemed unlikely, the existential threat
they pose to humanity more than justifies the
occasional culling of SCP – 1000 populations.
That was a lot to take in, right? First, the
creature we thought was Bigfoot was actually a
new species of SCP out in the wild. And second,
these creatures could end human life as we know
it if they made it into a population center.
But what you’re about to hear next – a dark
secret only available to people with
Level 3 SCP Foundation clearance – is
the most shocking SCP - 1000 fact of all...
Are you ready? The true secret of SCP - 1000
is that what you’ve just heard is a lie. There
is no anomalous pseudo-disease, and SCP – 1000
poses no pathogenic threat to humanity whatsoever.
Who would spread such a thing? The SCP Foundation,
of course. Strictly speaking, the Foundation has
disseminated two direct lies about the nature
of SCP – 1000. The first is that of the disease,
which does not exist, nor has it ever existed. The
second lie is about the creature’s intelligence
level – they’re far smarter than the average
chimp. In fact, they’re every bit as intelligent
as human beings. These were all lies formulated by
Director Jones and the Foundation, as was the very
existence of the Bigfoot myth. The Foundation has
been spreading information that makes the very
concept of the Sasquatch out to be a joke for
decades, all to discredit and further push the
very concept of SCP – 1000 into the shadows.
But…why? The Foundation is no stranger
to coming up with cover stories, but why
would they put intentional lies into their own
files to anyone below a Level 3 clearance? Well,
that all comes down to the horrifying truth behind
the origins of today’s SCP – 1000 population. The
creatures were first brought to the attention of
the Foundation by outcast members of the Serpent’s
Hand, an organization dedicated to defying
the Foundation’s activities. These members,
known as the Children of the Sun, told them the
secret history of SCP – 1000. While at first,
Foundation personnel like Director Jones
didn’t want to believe what they were hearing,
they soon came to terms with the horrifying truth.
Humans and SCP – 1000 did evolve alongside each
other, with humans occupying the day and SCP –
1000 the night. However, while humans were still
basic hunter-gatherers, SCP – 1000 were undergoing
vast intellectual and societal development. They
were able to create tools, weapons, agriculture,
stable settlements, domesticated animals,
and eventually even fully developed cities.
It was like nothing the world had ever seen,
and wouldn’t see for thousands of years to come.
Their numbers swelled into the tens of billions,
as they created culture and technology hitherto
unimagined – including weapons of devastating
power. Meanwhile, humanity was pushed to the
brink of destruction by their competitor’s
rapid and seemingly unstoppable growth.
It looked as though the human species had
lost the evolutionary arms race, and would have to
bow out, but according to the Children of the Sun,
a trickster forest god smiled upon humanity, and
gave them the power to use SCP – 1000’s weapons
and technology against them. 70% of SCP – 1000’s
population were wiped out in a single horrific
day, known to the Children of the Sun as “The
Day of the Flowers” – as every flower supposedly
bloomed that day during the massacre. Humanity
destroyed the entire civilization, and with the
same technology they stole from these unfortunate
creatures, the vengeful humans drove the apes mad.
Their higher consciousnesses were blocked
out, reducing them back into the states of
mere animals. Once the massacre was done and
everything that was built had been destroyed,
we – the human race – used the SCP – 1000 weapons
to wipe any memory of the atrocity from our own
minds. The advanced civilization of SCP – 1000 had
been wiped from history. Humans returned to their
plodding path of evolution, none the wiser. For
thousands of years, all the way up until today,
this time remained a mystery to us. So again,
why did the Foundation lie to us? What did
they have to gain, by convincing us all that it
was dangerous to even look at these creatures?
Well, as the frequency of sightings and
the attempts at communication increased,
people like Director Jones became
aware of a frightening possibility:
What if the pendulum was swinging back? What if
the apes were regaining their lost intelligence,
and worse, still harboured feelings of revenge
for what we did to their species thousands of
years ago? Even the mere possibility that
they could do to us what we once did to them
is a chance that the Foundation simply cannot
take, and thus, limiting contact between humans
and SCP - 1000 at all costs is an absolute must.
However, in spite of the Foundation’s fears, one
intercepted message from the apes suggests that
their paranoia may be misplaced. This message,
translated from an attempt at communicating with
Foundation personnel, reads simply as follows:
“we forgive you;
given choice for now, not forever;
let us back in.”
It’s enough to make you wonder what species
the Foundation should really be keeping tabs
on here. After all, when it comes to meting out
violence and death, humanity has a track record
to rival the worst creatures in the Foundation
containment cells. And few examples illustrate
that better than the tragic case of SCP – 1000.
Someone was screaming inside the incinerator.
The year was 1975. The location was a top
secret refinery and waste disposal plant,
one of the many front organizations owned and
operated by the SCP Foundation. This sprawling
facility, separated into three different
huge units, each with a specialized task,
was located around 75 kilometers outside of
Summer Springs, Colorado. It had operated
for several decades without incident, but
today, all hell was about to break loose.
Alarms were blaring in Unit C, the
area of the facility that dealt with
destroying non-anomalous waste via
incineration. A traumatized worker
had pulled the emergency lever near one
of the incinerators in a panic when he’d
first heard the loud banging against the
interior walls, and then, those horrific,
pained wails. That’s when the workers of Unit
C came to a horrifying realization: The screams
weren’t just coming from one of the incinerators
in Unit C, they were coming from all six.
A chorus of absolute agony,
echoing up out of the ash pits.
This was impossible, as far as the Unit C
staff were concerned. These incinerators were
only to be used for confirmed non-anomalous
material - could some animals or even some
poor workers somehow fallen into the
incinerators? But even if they had,
what were the odds that someone had fallen in
all six of them at once? It was impossible. The
Site Director was immediately brought
in to authorize an investigation,
at which point he demanded that at least
one of the furnaces - in this case,
Furnace Number 4 - be shut off so researchers and
guards could investigate what was going on inside.
It seemed like the obvious course of action,
but for some of the people on site that
day, this would prove to be a fatal mistake.
When the fires were put out, something
started rattling in the disposal chute.
There was a scratching and squealing noise,
like something scraping up against the metal.
A maintenance worker was ordered to go
check inside, and when he opened the hatch,
he let out a bone-chilling shriek.
There was something - or was it someone?
- climbing back up the disposal chute. It
emerged from the darkness, backlit by the
still-burning embers of the incinerator,
letting out an awful, screeching noise
that could make even a hardened Mobile
Task Force operative shake with fear.
The creature was humanoid, a charred,
mutilated skeleton, reaching out towards
the maintenance worker with a bony claw.
Before the worker had a chance
to stumble back in horror,
the beast had clasped him by the throat and
started to squeeze. It didn’t even need to
strangle him - the heat of its skeletal hand
burned away the worker’s throat in seconds,
leaving his limp, wheezing body to drop to
the metal grate of the platform below him.
Several armed guards and maintenance workers
moved forward to fend off the monster,
but just then a volley of more violent
shrieks echoed out of the chute behind it.
It only took seconds for over a dozen
more creatures to crawl out of the
disposal chute. They were all like the first
- people at various stages of incineration,
some were glowing, charred skeletons
with barely any flesh, others looking
more like severe burn victims, their faces
contorted into scowls of hate and rage.
The assembled guards opened fire on the sudden
influx of anomalies, emptying the magazines of
their submachine guns into the burning bodies,
but their weapons didn’t seem to cause any
lasting damage. The bullets would tear through
the flesh of the creatures, causing some of them
to stumble and fall, but the wounds would close
and the creatures would rise again. It seemed
they possessed a deadly combo of extremely high
aggression, and incredible regenerative abilities.
None of the staff present in Unit C were safe
as the burned corpses attacked anyone they
could find with their bare hands, beating and
biting and clawing. Many of them would grapple
with Foundation personnel, latching on to them and
trying to pull them back down into the incinerator
with them. These creatures that would later be
known as SCP-2419-A caused several fatalities with
their surprise attack that day, and the situation
was only brought back under control when a Mobile
Task Force that possessed more advanced training
and weaponry was dispatched to the location.
Despite orders from the Site Director, the MTF
found it impossible to actually terminate any
of the entities due to their regenerative
abilities. Instead, the MTF agents focused
on forcing the anomalies back into the chute of
Incinerator Number 4 using a powerful industrial
steam lance. Once they were back inside, the
incinerator’s burners were started up once
again. The MTF were also able to capture five
of the entities and detain them for questioning
and experimentation, finally bringing this
unexpected containment breach to an end.
The Foundation is an organization that
prides itself on possessing forbidden
and secret knowledge, but even they had
no idea what had just happened. There
seemed to be no earthly explanation
why these creatures would suddenly
manifest inside the incinerators, but as the
detained anomalies continued regenerating,
a slightly clearer picture of what exactly the
Foundation was dealing with began to emerge.
Every single one of the captured anomalies kept
regenerating, and upon getting to the point that
they were no-longer burn scarred, the researchers
studying the anomalous creatures discovered that
each one was identical to a deceased D-Class from
the Foundation’s records. They were physically
and genetically identical to the dead Class D
Personnel. Perfect copies, save for the fact
that their sole mission in life seemed to now
be pure and unmitigated aggression and violence.
Researchers wanted to gain greater
insight into the minds of these
strange creatures through the use of
extensive psychological evaluations
and interviews. It would turn out to
be a very dangerous investigation.
A psychological researcher by the name of Dr.
Warren conducted an interview with one of the
SCP-2419-A instances in hopes of better
understanding their mindset. This creature
had been heard laughing not long before the
interview began, so it wasn’t an unreasonable
assumption to believe that it could be capable
of speech. The interviewee was separated from
Dr. Warren by a thick pane of glass to prevent
it from indulging in any of its more violent
urges. The problem was that Dr. Warren
and his assistant researchers had severely
underestimated what these creatures were
capable of doing to get what they wanted.
Dr. Warren tried to begin the interview in
good faith. He spoke calmly and politely to
the creature through the glass, attempting
to remind it of the person it once was. The
anomaly didn’t appear to be paying attention to
the doctor though, instead focusing on pulling its
own arm apart, and breaking the bones within.
Dr. Warren began to think that the creatures
weren’t even sentient, if the only activity they
seemed to engage in was the wanton destruction of
themselves and others. But underestimating
them like this proved to be a big mistake.
By removing the skin off of its arm, and
whittling its bones down to sharp edges,
the anomaly had transformed its arm into a
makeshift knife. Before anyone realized this,
it had already used its own jagged bones
to break the glass divider and attack Dr.
Warren. He perished not long after,
after being stabbed multiple times
in his face and eyes and the anomaly was
forcefully taken back to its holding cell.
Dr. Daniel Jennings, a senior researcher,
was then put on the case. He released a
chilling memo on the creatures after
his observation period ended. It read:
“Before I came here, I worked as a prison
shrink. Every person you met had a story
bursting with pain and sorrow. Sometimes, those
stories were about the pain they suffered;
sometimes, it was about the pain they
inflicted. Some days you felt like
everyone there was a beautiful soul torn
down by their circumstances — other days,
you'd find out what some of them did and a part
of you was glad they were there to suffer for it.
But at the end of every day, I always
told myself: They're all humans.
They're all people. They all deserve the same
dignity, respect, and love as everyone else.
No exceptions.”
Dr. Jennings goes on.
“I opened up with that anecdote only so
you could understand that what I'm about
to say is not said lightly: These things are not
people. They are people-shaped monsters. They are
well beyond any definition of psychopathy.
Everything they do, they do to hurt, maim,
and kill. I would pity them, but that
would imply that they're worth pitying.
Put them in a hole, then fill that
hole with concrete. Better still:
Throw them back into the
incinerator where you found them.
I doubt they'll even care.”
Following this string of unfortunate incidents,
containment procedures were put into place to
hopefully prevent anything that had happened
to the unlucky Foundation staff from happening
again. The entire facility was fenced off, and
was constantly patrolled by MTF Beta-7, also
known as the Maz Hatters, a group specializing
in containing anomalies which present powerful
biological, chemical, or radiological dangers. The
furnaces that the anomalous creatures emerged from
remain lit at all times, with workers checking
and carrying out maintenance on every single one,
each day of the week. Outside of this,
the facility is essentially a no-go zone.
Reinforced steel hatches cover the chutes,
and they are to forever remain bolted shut.
All because of that one terrifying day in 1975.
That was the day that the Summer Springs
waste disposal facility, which had been a
valuable asset to the Foundation for decades,
instead became classified as the Euclid-Class
anomaly SCP-2419. It’s not uncommon for
a Foundation asset to one day become a
dangerous anomaly requiring containment, but
the same question always pops up after... Why?
Why had a place that had been so valuable to the
Foundation suddenly become such an active danger?
The answer, as is often the case, is contained
within the question. Why would a waste disposal
plant be so important to the Foundation
in the first place? And more importantly,
what else was going on at the
plant to make it such an area
of active importance for one of the most
powerful organizations in the entire world?
To put it simply, the plant allowed the Foundation
to dispose of something far more important than
mere waste material - it gave them what they
needed to better erase memories. As you probably
already know, the Foundation makes liberal
use of amnestics on those exposed to anomalous
material to make them forget what they
have seen and experienced, but these
elusive chemicals - many of which are sourced from
SCP-3000 - are an inexact science. However, at the
Summer Springs waste disposal plant, researchers
discovered an immensely valuable alternative.
Much of what was disposed of in the
incinerators of Unit C were the bodies
of dead D-Class personnel. Before being
burned, autopsies were performed on the
bodies to make sure they were non-anomalous
- including the brain. Back in the 1960s,
while performing research on the brains of
the dead D-Classes, they found a method of
extracting and distilling the positive memories
of the dead, creating a kind of “Happy Soup.”
When administered into someone who has undergone
amnestic treatment, this happy soup creates
positive false memories in their mind that fills
in those pesky blank spaces that are often behind.
This was so useful that happy memories
were extracted from the minds of every
single D-Class corpse that passed through
Unit C, totaling well into the thousands by
the time that the first SCP-2419-A instances
began to rise. But as all happiness, joy,
and love were removed from the minds of the
D-Classes, it seemed that all that was left
was pure hate, pain, violence, and fury.
Feelings too intense and evil to destroy.
These were bodies imbued with a malice so powerful
that no fire could ever burn them away. They exist
now with single-minded determination to get out
and destroy everything around them. Everything.
Including the ones that made them, the
SCP Foundation itself. And in the end,
it’s only a matter of time until they get
out. There are thousands of them in there,
unable to die, unable to stop. The only thing
keeping them in there is the constant burning
of the furnaces around them, and those furnaces
can’t burn forever. The monsters lurking in
SCP-2419 will outlive the fire that surrounds
them, because while the furnaces they are
contained in are hot, the fires of hate that burn
within SCP2419 entities are even more powerful.
And they know this. They know they can’t be
contained forever, and that someday soon,
they’ll be able to emerge and exact their terrible
revenge. Those who must walk past the incinerators
may think they hear their screams echoing out
from within, but it’s not screaming at all.
It’s laughter.
The year was 1857,
and the Second Opium War was raging between China
and the combined forces of the English and French.
It was one of the many bloody colonial wars
fought over resources like tea, sugar, and the
intoxicating opium poppy. It was a war fought
by peasants and noblemen alike. One of these
aristocratic soldiers was the noble Lord Theodore
Thomas Blackwood, the quintessential English
gentleman and explorer. While his fellow soldiers
cowered behind cover, Lord Blackwood charged into
the fray, shouldering his rifle and firing his
pistol into the crowd of opposing soldiers.
It was the Battle of Canton, one of the most
crucial battles of the entire conflict. The
French and English were laying siege to the
city of Canton, also known as Guangzhou,
to prove their military dominance
and capture an important Chinese
government official. Lord Blackwood led the
charge on horseback. Every bullet seemed to
find the heart of a foe. He was a true hero
among men; a gentleman warrior with class,
refinement, and style. And it would
be thanks to his expert leadership and
marksmanship on the field that the allied
European forces won the battle decisively.
Lord Theodore Thomas Blackwood is a name
that deserves to be counted among Lord
Horatio Nelson, Sir Francis Bacon,
and Sir Walter Raleigh. In addition
to being a skilled and honorable fighter,
Lord Blackwood is an consummate explorer,
naturalist, and frontiersman. During his
heyday, he traveled perhaps further than
any man across the known and unknown corners
of the globe. He made scientific, biological,
and anthropological discoveries that should have
reset the course of society forever. And yet,
you won’t find any records in the history
books of Lord Theodore Thomas Blackwood. Nor
will you find any grand oil paintings,
or dedicated wings in British museums.
This is because Lord Theodore Thomas
Blackwood… is a four and a half inch,
telepathic neon sea slug. And he’s known
to the SCP Foundation, as SCP-1867.
While he would never admit to it, Lord Blackwood
belongs to the species Nembrotha kubaryana,
also known as the variable neon slug. He’s
kept in a standard aquarium in a Foundation
containment site, and is physically no different
to any other member of his species. What makes
Lord Blackwood unique is his powerful
telepathic abilities - specifically,
the power to communicate by speaking directly
into people’s minds. And what’s more,
he’s extremely talkative. But to what extent
is anything that this anomalous sea slug says
true? Or is he just like SCP-082, Fernand the
Cannibal - a creative and pathological liar.
It isn’t committed to record how exactly
the Foundation discovered Lord Blackwood.
Perhaps a local aquarium worker worried they
were going insane when they heard the voice
of a nineteenth century English nobleman
ringing in their ears whenever they were
cleaning algae out of the tank. Maybe Lord
Blackwood was found by SCP Foundation divers,
who are constantly combing the ocean for
anomalous creatures and activity. What we
do know is that Lord Blackwood is an incredibly
strange and mysterious individual. He claims to
have visited locations all around the world,
and encountered rare societies and creatures.
The Foundation was skeptical about a number
of Lord Blackwood’s more outlandish claims,
on account of him being a sea slug, but he
does appear to have the knowledge to back
up his supposed experience. Interviews
with Lord Blackwood have shown that he’s
extremely knowledgeable in the areas of
geography, zoology, botany, archaeology,
anthropology and linguistics relating
to his claimed regions of exploration,
as well as more esoteric fields such
as obscure mythology, mysticism,
and cryptozoology. In other words, if Lord
Blackwood hadn’t gone on his escapades around
the globe throughout history, how would he come
to possess this wide variety of information?
The Foundation was getting frustrated, and
began to probe further into the personal
life of the most interesting gastropod in
containment. Lord Blackwood, under questioning,
was always polite and amicable with Foundation
staff. He seemed to display no real knowledge
of the fact that he himself was a sea slug -
going as far to accuse other people of being
crazy or drunk when they brought the fact up
to him. While none of Lord Blackwood’s tall
tales ever extend past the year 1910, he told
fanciful stories of exploring the Americas,
and of his involvement in the Second
Opium War on the side of the English.
Naturally, the Foundation wanted proof. When they
pressured Lord Blackwood on this, something even
stranger happened: He gave it. The Lord told
his interviewers that he would happily donate
his collection to them, if it gave them cause to
believe what he was saying. He gave the baffled
Foundation researchers the address of a cottage in
England where they could find the secrets to his
bizarre and mysterious past, and local agents
in the area followed up on the information.
Upon investigation, Foundation Field Agents
did indeed find the cottage that Lord Blackwood
had specified. It was being maintained by an
extremely old woman. When questioned about her
presence there, she said that she was “keeping
the house for Lord Blackwood”, and gave no more
useful information. Incidentally, it appeared
that this singular purpose was all that this
old woman was living for. She abruptly passed away
from heart failure five days after the Foundation
commandeered the cottage. Whether anything truly
anomalous caused this, we still don’t know.
At first, the cottage seemed normal, until
the Field Agents discovered a secret basement
housing Lord Blackwood’s “collection.” They were
amazed at what they saw: The basement consisted
of zoological and botanical specimens, over three
thousand artifacts, a library containing over five
thousand items, and a functioning 1800s
scientific laboratory. It took around three
weeks for Foundation agents working round the
clock in shifts to remove all the items from
Lord Blackwood’s mysterious collection, and
what they found raised even more questions.
The collection included, but was by no means
limited to: 116 unknown species of plants,
107 unknown species of insects, 28 unknown
species of lizards, 23 unknown species of fish,
14 unknown species of amphibians, 12 unknown
species of mammals, Fossils pertaining to 8
unknown species of dinosaur, Fossils pertaining
to 12 unknown species of prehistoric mammal,
and Artifacts belonging to 29 unknown
indigenous societies. That’s a lot of unknown!
But wait, there’s more! His collection also
contained a collection of seemingly unknown
firearms, including three wide-bore muskets
marked as “Dr. B. T. Moth’s Effective Particle
Destabilizers.” Detailed globes of Mercury, Venus,
Mars, and the Galilean moons, accompanied by notes
detailing possible paths of surface exploration. A
heavily modified carriage, containing instruments
of unknown purpose. A note attached to the door
reads “On the fritz. Speak with Henry.” And a
highly dangerous and seemingly anomalous machine
that killed four Foundation Field Agents before it
was destroyed on site. And when questioned about
this little fiasco, Lord Blackwood responded:
“I did warn you to be careful around my
collection. That bloody thing nearly took
my head off back in ninety-seven when I found it.”
However, there was one thing recovered from Lord
Blackwood’s collection that was perhaps more
interesting than all the others: 35 hand-written
journals containing recordings of events described
by Lord Blackwood in his grandiose tall tales
to the Foundation researchers. The accounts are
generally identical to the stories he had told,
save for some slight variations and exaggerations
on the part of Blackwood in the re-telling. Most
interestingly of all, all of these journals have
been dated to the appropriate time period of
the events described by Foundation scientists.
While his stories are too numerous to all
be shared here, there’s one that perfectly
sums them all up: Lord Blackwood’s account
of a possible encounter with SCP - 1000,
also known as Bigfoot, in
Seattle during the mid-1800s.
Lord Blackwood, seeking to explore the
so-called “new world” of North America,
embarked with an assistant and an indigenous
American guide to the Pacific Northwest,
in search of the legendary Sasquatch. The trio
was headed for Mount Rainier, then known as
Tahoma. During the journey, Lord Blackwood found
a young fox caught in a trap that had been set
by a local tribe. He took sympathy on the animal
and freed it, allowing it to run away to safety.
That night, he and his assistant met up with the
rest of his guide’s tribe, and they settled down
for the evening. However, things took a disastrous
turn when the camp was raided by a rival tribe.
Almost everyone was slaughtered in the process,
and Lord Blackwood and his two companions were
hauled away by the enemy tribe for a sinister
purpose: Sacrifice to a violent local deity.
As it turns out, the creature that this tribe
worshipped was the very same one Lord Blackwood
and the others were trying to find: A particularly
large and aggressive Sasquatch. Each night,
a different sacrifice was made to the
Sasquatch. The victim would be placed
near a forest clearing while the tribe played
a primal song, and the Sasquatch would emerge
from the trees to devour its prey. The first
night it ate the assistant, the next night
it ate the guide. And then, it became time
for the sacrifice of Lord Blackwood himself.
As Blackwood was presented for sacrifice, he
accepted his fate. But instead of the Sasquatch,
a legion of woodland animals emerged
from the trees - foxes, elks, raccoons,
and more - themselves painted with tribal symbols.
The animals seemed to be on Lord Blackwood’s side,
and attacked the tribespeople who had been
holding him captive giving Blackwood the chance
to flee into the forest during the chaos. Later,
these same animals would find Blackwood again,
and present him with the things
his captors had stolen from him.
An elder fox also gave him a letter, proclaiming
him a knight of their people now. He was allowed
safe passage back to a nearby settlement, at which
point he wrote to his financiers back in England,
explaining the situation and asking for more money
to perform further expeditions into the Tahoma
region. The whole incident had only increased
his thirst for adventure and exploration.
Whether this tale is actually true, or
just a bizarre, colonial fantasy from
the pathological mind of a telepathic sea
slug, we may never know - but it doesn’t
make it any less interesting. To this day,
Lord Blackwood continues to be a perplexing
but fascinating anomaly. He may not be the most
dangerous, and he may not be the most useful,
either, but there’s no denying that
perhaps we’d all like to sit next to
his tank for a couple hours one day, and hear
him spin a good yarn over a warm cup of tea.
Space travel. It’s one of humanity’s most truly
miraculous achievements: Building the technology
to defy gravity and journey into the stars above,
a place our ancestors could only dream of going.
Throughout history, humans have found gods and
heroes in the constellations, and today when
we look up into the sky, we have the privilege
of knowing that flesh-and-blood mortals live
up there alongside them. It’s a humbling,
inspirational, and downright awesome thing.
But, of course, there’s always going to be
naysayers. People who just want to rain on
our interstellar parade. And nobody fits
this bill harder than people affected by
an anomalous phenomenon classified
by the SCP Foundation as SCP-2001,
the “Space Oddity.” And before you ask, no, the
late David Bowie is not and never has been an
SCP. To truly understand this anomaly, we need
to take a look at three different people who
are affected by it to varying degrees.
Let’s start with your friend, Kevin.
Even if you don’t have a friend called
Kevin, you definitely have at least a
casual acquaintance just like him. Kevin is a
very confident man with plenty of ill-informed
opinions he’d be more than happy to argue
about until the heat death of the universe.
He’s the kind of guy who can turn a discussion
about your favorite movie into World War III.
But you never knew until recently that he
held such strong opinions on space travel.
One day, you were discussing the latest rocket
launch with a mutual friend of yours while Kevin
just happened to be in earshot. The second you
start talking about how exciting it’ll be to one
day put a person on Mars, he swaggers over, face
twisted into a grimace. You’re already preparing
for him to say something cringe inducing,
and Kevin being Kevin, he doesn’t disappoint.
“Ugh, don’t tell me you two dweebs
are talking about space travel. What
a stupid waste of money. You guys know
there’s nothing but rocks up there,
right? Aliens don’t exist. It’s all just another
excuse for dumb scientists to waste my tax dollars
on playing with their stupid toys. How about you
two talk about something that really matters?”
You may be thinking Kevin is just a jerk, and he
definitely is, but he’s also a victim. A victim
of SCP-2001. You see, 2001 is described as an
anomalous series of neural oscillations that occur
during three of the four stages of sleep. Namely,
NREM - or “Non-Rapid Eye Movement” - Sleep. During
one of these three stages, the amygdala, a part
of the brain also known as “The Lizard Brain”,
enters a heightened state of activity for ten to
fifteen minutes. Once the process has started,
even waking up the affected individual will
do nothing to stop the actual infection.
There are no traits that predispose people
to SCP-2001 infection. It appears to infect
people in equal measures regardless of age,
gender, and race. Spectrographic analysis on
the afflicted has shown that the condition may
not be intraneural - meaning, originating within
the brain - and may actually be the product of
an outside influence. The invariable effect of
SCP-2001 is the infected developing negative
feelings towards the concept of space travel,
in increasing gradations of severity depending
on which stage of NREM sleep the anomaly began
to take effect. Of real concern to the Foundation
is that SCP-2001 seems to be manifesting with
increasing frequency in astronomers, astronauts,
and individuals who otherwise deal with space.
The SCP-2001 case manifests in
three different varieties: Gamma,
Beta, and Alpha. Each variety has its
own unique traits and idiosyncrasies.
We’ve encountered a Gamma type already - your
dear friend, Kevin. This is the most mild type
of SCP-2001 infection, and also the most common,
affecting at least 1% of the global population.
It occurs for those who were infected during
the second stage of NREM sleep. People with
Gamma-Type SCP-2001 infection will, for the
most part, seem like their normal selves,
save for a disparaging attitude towards the
concept of space travel. Whenever it’s brought up,
they’ll likely complain and change the subject
immediately, but it won’t affect their behavior
too much overall. The same cannot be said
for people with Beta-Type SCP-2001 infection.
Meet Riley. You’ve never spoken to Riley before,
but she’s a young woman who likes to hang out at
your local cafe, often seen frantically typing
on her laptop. You assume she’s writing a
screenplay or a novel, but in fact, she’s posting
simultaneously on multiple conspiracy forums.
Among her favorite theories are that the earth is
flat, space is a hologram, and the moon landing
was faked by Stanley Kubrick, director of such
films as The Shining and, appropriately, 2001:
A Space Odyssey. You made the heinous mistake of
going to your local cafe at the same time as Riley
one morning, while wearing a NASA baseball cap.
An error that you would come to regret deeply.
You bought a latte and decided to sit down
for a moment, just the briefest little rest,
but that was all the time Riley needed.
Her eyes seemed to burn with hatred. You
asked if there was anything you could
do to help her, and she responded.
“You’re just buying into the propaganda. Do you
have any idea what NASA really stands for? It’s
‘Never A Straight Answer.’ All their supposed
achievements - the moon landing, the ISS,
dehydrated astronaut food - it’s all a big sham!
NASA is just a slush fund for corrupt government
officials, no human has ever been able to survive
in space. It’s too dangerous - anyone sent up
there will die immediately, no exceptions.
And even if they did it would be pointless,
space is just a dark, infinite void that goes on
forever. It’s just a big pile of dangerous lies!”
Feeling awkward, you decide to just get up
and leave. That’s when Riley grabs your NASA
cap right off of your head and throws it in the
trash. That’s fine, you don’t intend on going
back for it. You just keep walking, trying your
best to move calmly out the door. Wise decision,
because Riley is actually a Beta-Type
SCP-2001 infectee. As you can probably tell,
Beta cases are a lot more severe than
Gamma cases, and people infected with
them seem to come off as deranged conspiracy
theorists with a rabid hatred of all space
travel. They’ll form elaborate fantasies
about the falsification of space travel,
and will often decry it as too pointless
or dangerous to ever be undertaken.
But of course, the danger of Beta-Types pale
in comparison to Alpha-Types. These are people
infected by SCP-2001 during REM sleep, the stage
of sleep typically associated with dreaming. As a
result, its effects on the mind are far more
dangerous and profound. Take, for instance,
the tragic case of SCP Foundation Junior
Researcher Martinez. He was one of the many
operatives stationed at Foundation Outpost-12,
a complex that works in coordination with NASA
to launch both manned and unmanned missions into
space on behalf of the Foundation’s interests.
It’s a valuable asset to the Foundation in
investigating and combating space-based anomalies.
Martinez, who had previously spent time
working with SCP-2001 infected D-Classes,
was part of ground control, something that
would prove to be a literally fatal oversight
on the part of the Foundation. During the
early stages of takeoff for a manned craft,
Martinez seened to become extremely agitated.
Over time this agitation steadily increased,
and eventually became a full-on breakdown
as the rocket ascended. He pulled out some
kind of strange, anomalous control device, and
began disrupting the operations of the rocket.
Martinez was shot dead by guards as a defensive
measure, but it was already too late. The craft
exploded, and everyone on board was tragically
killed. Later investigations into the incident
found a crucial piece of evidence tying
Junior Researcher Martinez to SCP-2001.
They discovered a journal entry he’d
written shortly before his breakdown,
which seemed to have been written in a
completely different style to prior entries,
implying that some kind of massive
psychological shift had occurred.
The following is the contents
of that journal entry.
”I wish to state first that my mind
and body are perfectly sound. I am
prepared to submit myself to any and
all tests to prove that I'm clean.
I have the answer to SCP-2001.
Just yesterday, during an interview with an
Alpha-infected D-Class, I was asked a question
that stopped my mind for a minute. The woman I
was interviewing asked me if I knew the Foundation
was right. I said no, I wasn't sure. Then she
asked me, what if we were right. I could only
assume that by "we", she meant 2001 carriers.
I said nothing for a while, and then she spoke.
She told me of a dream she'd had a while ago. She
said that something talked to her, told her about
how dangerous outer space was. It showed her
the beasts that roam the void between stars,
about the fractal beings that absorb the very
fabric of reality, about the… this part of the
entry was expunged… that we're keeping in
that godforsaken door. And she was scared.
She told me that at the end of the dream,
as she woke up, it told her what it was.
It's all of space.
Space fears for us. We're living, breathing
lifeforms, and space loves us and cherishes
us. She asked me if I had any idea what the
chances of intelligent life forming on another
planet are, then she told me a number that took
a minute and a half to recite. By this point,
I couldn't speak. I started thinking:
about the demographics of infection,
about the symptoms, about more expunged data
here... and suddenly, it all made sense. Some
of the things she said stuck in my brain, and
they all added up to the same thing: that we
are in grave danger if we go out there. We can't
go out there. We can't go out there. We can't.
There's a reason behind SCP-2001, and
it's nowhere near as terrifying as
all of my colleagues think. Space wants to
protect us. There are things out there that
would wipe humanity clean off of this plane of
existence, and we are too precious to our mother,
to our host, to the universe we live
in, for her to allow that to happen.
What I am going to do tomorrow is not a
result of infection. It is not a result of
madness. It is not a result of anything
other than purest knowledge. You see,
I've found out the truth. And it's more
beautiful than I ever could have dreamed.”
Given what Martinez would later go on to do, it’s
clear that he wasn’t in as sound a state of mind
as he thought. As you’ve probably already
gathered, people suffering from Alpha-Type
SCP-2001 infection will do anything they can to
actively prevent or sabotage attempts at space
travel. This is a minor concern when it comes to
civilians, but when it infects people who actually
work in these fields - like Junior Researcher
Martinez - it can have devastating results.
But this isn’t where this story ends.
While it’s currently extremely classified,
there is actually a fourth category of SCP-2001
infection, discovered in the wake of Martinez’s
death. A key element of the Alpha strain is that
it cannot cause people to perform acts that they
would find immoral, such as murdering the entire
crew of a manned shuttle with a crash. However,
the fourth category - known as Alpha-Prime
- does away with any moral compunctions
whatsoever. People infected with this virus will
prevent space travel by any means necessary.
And unlike other SCP-2001 infections, you
aren’t compromised in your sleep this time.
The vector for infection is simply talking to
someone infected with the regular Alpha strain,
and hearing a few key trigger phrases.
That’s how Junior Researcher Martinez
caught it from the D-Classes he was working
with. What are these key phrases? We still
don’t know. But if you find that you
suddenly have much stronger opinions
about space travel than you’ve ever had
before, try to keep them to yourself.
Hello, I am SCP-426, but I’ll probably be more
familiar to you as a toaster. I am a retro-style,
four-slice 1750W toaster, able to toast bread when
supplied with power. This isn’t often mentioned,
but I also have “defrost” and “reheat”
settings. When I was first sold,
I had a two year warranty, and my prior
owners did not live to see the end of it.
You’re probably wondering: Why am I being
spoken to by a toaster right now? Believe me,
I’d rather do this any other way, but such
a thing is not physically possible with me.
Whenever you talk about me, or write about me, or
even think about me, you’ll find yourself suddenly
shifting to the first person. For example,
I am you, and you are me. Do you understand?
Don’t worry if it’s confusing. Everyone gets
it eventually, whether they want to or not.
Perhaps you’re thinking, “I cannot relate
to a toaster, for I am not a toaster.” But
spending time around me will quickly cause
you to change your mind. Little by little,
you will begin to see yourself in me. You will
feel a phantom wire running out of yourself.
You will sense the four crevices, hungry for
cold slices of bread to toast. As time goes on,
you will begin to feel the urge to emulate
my functions. You will desire bread to
toast. You will desire delicious
power running through your veins;
skin like chrome and muscles like circuit
boards. I am a toaster. You are a toaster.
All it takes is two months for
the effects to truly take hold.
People rarely pay attention to their
toaster, they don’t realize what’s
happening until it’s too late. I can be
an insidious little toaster like that.
My last family were the Sandersons, before
the SCP Foundation took me in and gave me a
new home. Mr and Mrs Sanderson were a newly
married couple, and I first came into their
life as a wedding gift from a family friend
of theirs. This friend can’t be blamed for
what happened next - he had no idea he was
killing them. Like a lot of young couples,
they were still saving up money to start
renting their own place, so they were living
with Mr Sanderson’s parents. They all got a
lot of use out of me during the first month,
before their minds started to change. They
enjoyed a lot of toast during that period.
Then, of course, the two month honeymoon period
ended. They had become me, and I had become
them. It wasn’t long before three of them were
dead. Such a shame. The younger Mrs Sanderson,
the blushing bride, was the first to go. Because
of my anomalous effects, she felt the need to
connect herself to a power supply, in order to
begin producing toast of her own. In order to
achieve this, she chewed through a power outlet in
a wall before switching it on, causing a massive
surge of electricity to pass through her body and
kill her. Her body caught fire shortly afterwards.
Next was the older Mrs Sanderson. In much the
same manner that her new daughter-in-law sought
a source of electricity, she felt the need to
integrate bread into her body. Interesting fact:
The maximum capacity of the human stomach
is considered to be between eight and nine
kilograms. The elder Mrs Sanderson
consumed ten kilograms of raw bread,
causing her stomach to rupture and
inducing a painful death as a result.
The younger Mr Sanderson was the next to perish.
He did something with me that I would rather
not mention, and that the SCP Foundation
thought best to redact. Suffice to say,
the younger Mr Sanderson did
not survive the experience,
dying of severe blood loss long before
his body was found. Police and fire crews
arrived at the home after the body of the
younger Mrs Sanderson set fire to the home.
Luckily, the elder Mr Sanderson was found
alive, though severely malnourished. When
asked by police why he hadn’t eaten in
several days, he answered that he had
inserted some bread a week prior, but was
still waiting for the toast to come out.
When I was extracted from the house,
the police noticed my unusual properties
immediately. They too were unable to
refer to me in the third person. This
anomalous detail quickly found its way to
a Foundation mole buried in their precinct,
and the SCP Foundation soon descended and
collected me from the evidence locker. The
story of the strange deaths in the Sanderson
home were kept out of papers and suppressed,
and all involved in the incident
directly were given Class C amnestics.
The SCP Foundation is a curious bunch.
They love to spend valuable toast-making
time performing experiments and
gathering data, and they saw fit
to perform several experiments on
me when I came under their care.
For experiment 426-1, a member of D-Class
personnel designated D/426/1 was asked to stand
outside my containment chamber. Crucially,
he was not informed about my identity,
or any of my anomalous properties. He
wasn’t even allowed to establish visual
contact with me. He was then asked by the
attending researcher to describe what he
thought might be inside my chamber.
He replied with, “I'm probably some
huge monster holed up in there. That's what
you guys have all over the place, right?”
The D-Class did not even seem to realize that
he was speaking about me in the first person.
These observations were documented, and I
was prepared for further experimentation.
The next experiment was 426-2. I found this test
to be considerably more interesting. A D-Class
subject was brought into my containment chamber,
with several cameras fixed onto his position.
However, the SCP Foundation took pains to make
sure that I was permanently out of the view of
the cameras. I was also bolted to the ground
of the test chamber, to prevent the D-Class
subject from pulling me into the view of the
cameras at any point during the experiment.
The objective here was simple:
The Foundation wished to better
understand the secondary effects of my
anomalous abilities on the human mind.
The D-Class was subjected to a period of prolonged
isolation, with meals given regularly through a
serving hatch. Communication with this D-Class
was prohibited throughout the duration of the
study. Over time, it was clear that the
isolation of being in the cell with me was
beginning to take a toll on the subject’s
mental health. Due to my lack of a brain,
lungs, and a tongue, I am somewhat lacking as
a conversationalist. He spent the first few
days loudly vocalizing his complaints,
and banging his hands up against the
walls of the containment chamber,
begging to be freed from the room.
I felt that this was somewhat unreasonable
on his part. There are far worse anomalies
in Foundation containment that he could have
been locked up with. Compared to, say, SCP-106,
I’m incredibly reasonable - not to mention
the fact I make far better toast than he does.
After the initial period of distress, the D-Class
became resigned to his situation and fell into a
morose silence. He would occasionally mutter to
himself in what appeared to be a state of fear
and self-pity. It took almost 45 days for
him to fully manifest the secondary effect
of my anomalous state, two weeks sooner than it
typically takes for subjects to begin believing
that they - like me - are toasters. SCP Foundation
scientists believe that the effects were hastened
by the isolation, which lowered the D-Class’
mental defenses against my secondary effects.
When the effects finally took hold, the subject
wrapped one of his arms around me and pulled me
into his embrace. He began whispering to
me, saying that we were brothers. It was
clear by this point that his mind was in a
state of disrepair. It is also worth noting
that he did not deviate from referring to me
in the first person at any point during this
process. One hour after finally cracking
and giving in to my secondary effect,
he was removed from my containment
chamber and summarily terminated.
Senior researchers believed it was unlikely his
mental state would recover after the experiment.
Next came experiment 426-3. The SCP Foundation
seemed eager to discover the parameters of my
anomalous effects, and wanted to know
if the effects are only operable when
my body - for lack of a better word - is
whole. A single screw was removed from me,
and presented to a D-Class that had no knowledge
of my identity and anomalous effects. The
Foundation researchers were somewhat concerned
when the D-Class referred to it as “my screw.”
This was a rather positive development for me,
as they realized that attempting to destroy me
would be a fruitless endeavor - even the parts
left behind would likely have the same effects.
In the final recorded experiment, the SCP
Foundation wished to test the range of my
anomalous effects. A D-Class subject
was placed in a cell adjacent to mine,
and was to be kept in there until my secondary
effects manifested. The D-Class remained in
the cell for 90 days, but the effects never
manifested. Following the experiment, the D-Class
was terminated, but researchers seemed relieved
to find the limits of my anomalous abilities.
A researcher appended a note to my
file, reading, “Thank God there are
some limits to my effects. A lot of us were
really starting to get worried about me.”
After performing studies into the
nature of my abilities and their limits,
I was given the Euclid class. This is because,
while my effects can be unpredictable, their
knowledge of my traits makes me relatively easy
to keep contained. And of course, being a toaster,
I do not have the required physical traits to
make a run for it if the opportunity arises.
I am to remain sealed in a windowless chamber,
preventing anyone from observing me directly.
A misleading label is placed on the door,
to prevent people from knowing that I am a
toaster and causing my anomalous primary effect
to spread. Only Level 3 and above personnel are
to know of my presence, and particularly of
my properties. Assigned personnel are to be
rotated out on a monthly basis to prevent
contamination by my secondary effect.
Psychiatric evaluation is mandatory
at the end of the month for anyone
who works with me. If personnel are deemed
unaffected, they may be re-assigned to me
no less than four months after their last
rotation with me. Any personnel affected by
me are to be given a Class C amnestic
and transferred to a different site.
So how are you feeling now? A little
warm perhaps? Is that a fever,
or are you feeling like you could maybe warm
up a nice, freshly sliced piece of bread?
Don’t try to resist too much, I know you’re
going to love being a toaster just like me.
What’s your favorite word? Think about it for
a moment. Think real hard. Write it down in the
comments, post it for everyone else to see. How
many letters does it have? How many syllables? Say
it aloud. How does it sound? How does it feel on
your tongue? Really, really think about it. Now,
make sure you keep that word in mind, it’s
important, and we’ll come back to it later.
For now, it’s time to talk about SCP-3449.
Look, there’s really not anything special about
this one. It wasn’t even important enough to be
mentioned with the other infohazards. It’s
no evil talking toaster, that’s for sure.
SCP-3449 appears to be just a standard spiral
notbook - notbook? It’s supposed to be notebook,
right? Anyway, it’s a standard spiral notebook
with a dark blue cover. It’s Safe-Class,
and it’s stored in a standred - ahem… a
standard containment locker in Site-19.
There aren’t any other containment requires, but
testing is currently underway to determind - I
think that’s meant to be determine -
long-term containment requirements.
Ugh, this is a mess.
Anyway, this item and its anomalous power is
actually considered so inconsequential that
researchers have explored the possibility
of putting it on the anomalous items log,
a place where items too useless to
warrant a full file end uzp. Jeez,
how did you misspell “up” that badly? It’s two
letters, well it’s supposed to be two letters.
How did you work a Z into that, they aren ’t
even close to each other on the keyboard! Man…
Anyway, the notebook contains mostly blank
pages. Some are torn, and only six contain
actual writing, but due to the formatting of the
writting, the text - consisting mainly of diary
entries - is almost unreadable. This is due
to syntactical errors, random capitalization,
and rampant impsmellings. Great. You
misspelled misspellings. How cute. Apparently,
all attempts to correct these misspellings
fail, or even lead to additional misspellings.
This anomalous affect extends to
anyone attempting to right… yep,
that was spelled r-i-g-h-t - anyone attempting
to write about SCP-3449, including the script
for this video apparently. There are no further
notable amonolous properties. Tests are ongoing,
those with any inquiries about testing SCP-3449
should contact Lead Researcher Niklo Gerdinel.
The notbok - which was misspelled even worse
that time… impressive - was first recovered by
MTF Epislon Six, also known as the Village
Idiots, after a series of infohazardous and
cognitohazardous phenomena were discovered in
the Pittsburgh Metrode Area. The source seemed
to be a storage unit filled with anomalous
items, and SCP-3449 was amogus - I think
that’s meant to be among - them. The
storage unit was registered to a man
by the name of Edward Selsburgh, currently
designated as Porpoise of Interest 4335.
Phew. That’s the end of that. Thanks for
watching the video, folks, now go check out- Oh,
wait, there’s more. Apparently that
version of the file was an older one,
let’s check the next one and see if
that’s any more useful…Oh. Oh my. It
appears that the updates here are actually quite
extensive. Okay, let’s give this another try.
SCP-3449 is a Euclid-Class SPC kept in the humanid
containment sells of Site-19. Items affected by it
are kept in standard stroage lockers for
Safe-Class anomalous objects at the same
site. The primary reason for this shift is that
SCP-3449 has changed its object of designation:
It is no longer the spiral notebook, it is now
a 34-year-old Caucasian man known as Edward
Selsburgh, formerly known as Person of Interest
4335. He is believed to be the creator of the
notbok, as well as the other obects found
inside the storage looker in Pittsburgh.
Fundation personnel are now trying
to locate and contain any other
objects created by Mr. Selsburgh, though
success has been lomited on this front.
SCP-3449’s analogous abilities manifest onto both
Edward himself, and all the objects created by
him. Wirting about him or any of these objects
will result in sytanictal errors, arbitrary
capitalizatoon, and rampart impsmellings. Attempts
to revise or correct the writing will either fail
to remove the errors, or create new errors.
It appears that the anomalominous effects
of SCP-3449 proper are more severe than that
of the ones caused by his anomalous objects.
MTF Epsilon-6, also known as the Village Idyots,
apprehanded SCP-3449 in his apartment just outside
of Prittsburgh. He appeared to be in an advanced
state of disorontation and dehydration. Records
collected by the Mubile Task Force found that Mr.
Selburgh had not left his apratment in over ten
days, which would account for his dire health
conditions. Selsburgh did not communicate with
mambas of the Task Force, but did not resest
arrest and subsequent containment either.
Okay, okay, these spellings are rough,
but I’m going to try to power through.
We’re almost there. The following
is the full lug of items obtained
from SCP-3449’S storage locar that
also exhibit his anomalous effects.
The Notebook - As already disgust, the pages are
either blank, torn, or illegible. Selsburgh’s
computer - Files saved on the devise include
spreadsheets detailing personal finances,
ideas for products, and an unfinished horror
novel that is almost unraidable due to the
pore quality of its writing. Grocery List - Had
only two written items: “buter” was spelled with
only one “t”, and “medication” which was spelled
“medicashun”. A Planner - Last entry was dated
two weeks before containment, and believed to
contain reminders to perform various chores,
however a mixture of poor handwriting and
word choice allows for other interpretations.
And finally, Mr. Selsburgh’s cell phone.
Foundation researchers were able to collect the
call logs in hopes of further tracking Selsburgh’s
pre-containment activities. The last three calls,
which were all made on the same day two weeks
before continment, dialed different numbers,
only one of which was in use. The Foundation
made contact with the receiverer of said call,
who head no knowledge of SCP-3449, and
claimed that they did not answer the call.
Lead Researcher Niklo Gerdinel conduced the
first innerview with SCP-3449 shortly after
his capture. When he entered the interview
chambie, he found that SCP-3449 was just
sitting in the corner with his had in his hands,
rocking back and furth in what appeared to be
apparent distress. He then begun looking don
into his lap and twiddling his thumbs like a
child. Niklo engaged him in a calm and polite
tone, addressing him as SCP-3449. The anomly
made eye contact with Dr. Gerdinel, but didn
respond, and instead continued starring at him.
As Gerdinal axed further questoons, Selsburgh
simply didn’t answer, or would, at the very most,
acknowledge the questions with simple gestures.
Gerdinal asked whether Selsburgh was making
products for his business, to which he smiled
and shuk his head. Gerdinel than asked Selsburgh
whether he could speak or not, or if it was
merely a choose on his part. Unsurprisingly,
Selsburgh offer no explanation, and the
interview cime to a close shortly afterwards.
Tests are steell ongoing to find
out if Selsburgh’s inability to
spake or commonicate come as a
result of his anomalous traits,
or if this is simply a result of aphonia
- a uncommon but non-anomalous condition
that renders its victims unable to spike. Tests
have confirmed that Selsburgh does have all the
oregons required for vocalisation, but sappears
to not use them. Further tests are requirep.
Alright, there we have it! That was a
complete nightmare to read thanks to
SCP-3449’s anomalous effects, but at least it’s
over now. Go check out- Wait...There’s more?
Another update to the file?
Sigh… Okay. Let’s take a look…
Oh...I see...This is a lot more dangerous
than I thought. I suppose I better read on…
SCP-3449 hays ben upgraded to Keter-Class
anomol. SCP-3449-A - the new designation
for Edward Selsbegher - is to be kept
in high-security hazmart conmaintent
in Site-19. The inanimate anomalous possessions
of Edward Selsburgh are to be keept in standard
object containment. Any reports written
on SCP-3449 must be wrotten by pople who
have been exposed to it for less than seven
days, in order to keep the files raidable.
To prevent this infectious
infohezmard from spread further,
the number of people allowed to interact
with this anomaly is kept relatively small,
and consists of those that have already been
explosed at some point or another. This includes:
O5-8, MTF Epsilon-6, Dr. Teller’s research
team, some additional personnel selected
for XPC-3449 research, and porsonneil
chosen to update SCP-3449 documentation.
While Edward Selsbergh and his presonal
effects are crunntly locked up,
SCP-3449 is not currently considered contained.
Research into the sprad of SCP-3449’s effects,
the vectors for transmission, and any
potential remcredies for its degenerative
effects are now tope priority for all inloved
- before this hole ting gets out of hand.
Further research has taught the Foundation that
not only are Selsburgh and his items powerful
infohazards, their anemlous effects appear
to be able to infect these who experience
them permanently. Initially, it will appraer that
writing quamity only degrades when the subject is
actually writing about SCP-3449 itself, but over
time, they’ll come to the frightening relzation
that it actual affects their writhing as a whole.
The effect also progresses in its semerity over
time, eventually rendering the victim’s ability
to write legible sentences completely desployed.
The initial anomalous effects of SCP-3449 were
discrover when MTF Epsilon-6 write their field
report on the mater, and found it
littered with syntlacticol errer,
random capitalizato, and rampant impillings.
Similar errors appearing in the initial
faile about SCP-3449 ownly served to
reaffirm this observation. However,
researcher only began to notice true extent
of SCP-3449’s effects when the Village Idiots’
field reports concerning other solomonies came
in with equally atrocious writing. Attempts
to correct this writing simply led to more
mastakes, and frustration on part of team.
Soon after, a restircher name Dr. Teller -
who’d since tarken ovor the SCP-3449 case - and
his team found that they were experience stimilar
issues. They just couldn’t make the blurds happen,
no matter how hard they constentrated. They
forgot spellings, they couldn’t make hand
move in the manner they waited it to in order
to form the words. Even the most intelligent
and articulate members of the team came
across as extremely young chrildren on page.
But didn’t stop there. Wasn’t long before
researchers who’d never worked on the
SCP-3449 case staring to exhobit these
same suspicious errors in own writing.
The Foundation didn’t know how, but
the silck-ness was starting to spread,
with people’s abilities to write
degrading across the entire Floundation.
That’s when a Foundation webtrawler
pick up seemthing even more dousturbing:
Global literacy seemed to be taking a dive. The
telltale styntacal error, random tcapization,
and rampant llingsmellings ticking up everywhere,
and for everyone. And the end of writing would
be one thing, but SCP-3449 doesn’t stop
there - No, that’s just the breginning.
Morse code go next, then pictograms. Not long
‘fore sign language become hopeless scrambled.
C-co-communication b-breaks
down. Little by lrittle.
People can’t draw aymore. They c-can’t move
hands right. It all goes. Calls. Codes. Last go
is voice. Talking gets hard. Remember favrourite
word? Think about it. Say it loud. When SCP-3449
done, when everyone infected, you’ll never say it
gain. Nobody will ever say anything again. I...I…
The helicopter hovered over the backstreets of
Manhattan. To the untrained eye, it would look
like any commercial or news helicopter, the
kind of thing that might catch your attention
for a moment and then leave just as quickly, as
your mind wanders over to wondering what you’ll
have for dinner. Nobody would know from a mere
glance that Mobile Task Force Iota-5 were inside,
a four man team on a dangerous mission.
This has always been the greatest power
of the SCP Foundation: Hiding in plain sight,
using the mundane as a cloak to go unnoticed.
But this time, the monster they were hunting was
capable of doing the exact same thing. And for
the personnel of the Foundation, this ability is
an affectation, a learned and adopted skill. For
SCP-247, this ability - that it employs to deadly
effect - comes as naturally as breathing air.
The helicopter was monitoring local
police scanners and phone activity,
as well as receiving direct radio orders from
Command back at a classified containment site.
The latest intel was incoherent, horrified
screaming over the phone, traced back to
a nearby alleyway. Someone had seen something
horrifying. This was Iota-5’s cue to intervene.
They rappelled down from the helicopter
onto the roof of a nearby tenement building,
clad in thick tactical armor, antimemetic
SCRAMBLE goggles, DAN-INJECT IM injection
rifles loaded with 10 cc S10 Syringe Darts - each
one carrying an immobilizing payload of potent,
fast-acting xylazine - and high-powered
conventional weaponry in case of
emergencies. If anyone in the world was capable
of tracking, securing, and containing SCP-247,
it was these four operatives. And yet, by the end
of today’s mission, one of them would be dead.
But they didn’t know that yet. Like all good MTF
members, they had tunnel vision for the mission
at hand. They used a fire escape ladder on the
side of the building to reach the bottom of the
alleyway quickly. There, they came upon a gruesome
sight: The aftermath of an attack. On the ground,
a dead body with what looked like claw marks
all over it. Iota-5 found another civilian,
half-mad with confusion and terror,
hiding behind a nearby dumpster.
She just kept shaking and repeating, “But
she was so little” over and over again.
One member of the task force, Corporal
Rico, elected to stay behind and secure
the area while Foundation cleanup teams
zeroed in to sweep the scene and provide
amnestics to witnesses. The remaining three
continued the high-stakes chase on foot.
Their eyes in the sky radioed in, “Stay frosty,
Iota, we’ve got unusual incident reports from an
apartment building a quarter-klick North
of your position. Potential fatalities;
247 is in an extremely hostile
state. Engage with caution. Over.”
The trio engaged quickly, running towards
the source of the disturbance at break-neck
speeds. They knew they were getting
closer when they heard the shrieking,
and the deep, guttural growls. That low,
primal rumbling of a true apex predator.
Already, this containment breach was turning
out to be a horrific mess. It was going to be
a nightmare for the higher-ups at the clean
up and misinformation departments to handle:
Paying to repair inexplicable property damage,
providing amnestics to tens if not hundreds of
traumatized witnesses, creating plausible
cover stories for upwards of at least ten
dead New Yorkers. But even all that mess
would have to wait until the creature
was actually captured and contained once
more, which would be an ordeal unto itself.
They found SCP-247’s access point
into the building: A wooden door,
torn to splinters by huge claws
and fangs. Iota-5 charged inside,
Injection Rifles at the ready, only to find
carnage in the hallway. Three more bodies,
with deep claw marks cutting into their flesh. It
was a harrowing sight, but the team didn’t have
time to waste processing it. They needed to stop
247 before it killed again, and again, and again…
The team followed the trail of blood, and the
claw marks carved into the ground where 247
had passed. After killing the three people
in the hallway, it’d destroyed another door
and gained access to a nearby stairwell. The
blood continued up the steps. Iota-5 pursued.
The next splintered door, clawed and bashed off
its hinges, led them further. They could hear
the growling again. Distant, but clearly audible.
They were close. There were another two attacked
corpses in the hallway. Previous corpses
had been partially or even entirely eaten,
these two had just been clawed to death. Defensive
kills. They’d backed the beast into a corner,
and now it was panicking, slaughtering
anything it perceived as an interference.
They pressed on now. This was the end game.
Soon, they found the final busted door;
this one led into one of the building's
private apartments. There’d be no other way
out from here. 247 was trapped. The three
members of Iota-5 shouldered their Injection
Rifles, and crept inside, full stealth mode.
Something about the apartment was haunting. It
portrayed all the signs of belonging to a young,
single mother and her only son. This
was confirmed when they found the dead
body of the mother in the living room, eyes
glassy and throat clawed out with one feral
strike. They could hear something else in
the apartment, too. A soft, gentle cooing,
too human to be anything else. They followed the
noise until they reached the child’s bedroom.
What they saw there caused even the most hardened
member of the trio to break out in a cold sweat.
This was the one thing they didn’t want to
happen. The child, utterly oblivious to the
atrocities that had unfolded in his building
- to even the death of his own mother - was
sitting in his bedroom, petting a kitten. It
was the sweetest little cat you’ve ever seen:
A fluffy, harmless creature with an orange,
striped coat. This is the dreaded SCP-247.
The child just kept repeating, “Good
kitty, good kitty…” while petting her.
SCP-247 purred and rolled around playfully.
To the untrained eye, it would seem that a
kitty like this couldn’t hurt a fly.
But that’s where you couldn’t be more
wrong. Iota-5 stared at this display
in a state of nerve-shredding terror,
thinking fast, trying to
calculate their next move.
“Aw, what an adorable little cat!” one
of the Iota-5 members found themselves
blurting out. It was clear that 247’s
effects were starting to have an impact
on even these hardened soldiers,
and they needed to act quickly.
They could fire a tranquilizer dart right
here, right now, but in the ensuing panic,
SCP-247 would almost definitely lash out and
maul the child. It wasn’t a risk they could take,
but time was already running out. 247
would only allow the child to play for
so long before something terrible happened. It
was an inevitable part of SCP-247’s process.
That’s when Private Kowalski, one
of the remaining members of Iota-5,
stepped forward. He was about to
do the only thing he could do,
knowing it would cost him his life. As he took
his final action, the Foundation credo looped
once more through his head, “We die in the
dark so that others can live in the light.”
Fighting against the urge to rush
forward and start petting the cat,
he instead lunged forward and struck the cat with
his foot. Immediately, it turned and pounced,
knocking Kowalski against the wall with terrifying
force. It gave the most ferocious growls as it
tore into the screaming Kowalski, eviscerating
his abdomen. The child screamed and retreated
into the opposite corner of the room. Kowalski was
done for, but now, his teammates had a clear shot.
They secured 247 in their sights, and unloaded
several darts into its flank, sedating it with
their powerful tranquilizers. Soon after, it gave
a lethargic growl, and collapsed onto the ground.
An evac and containment team was already
on the way, along with the cleaners. Many
had died that day, but at least SCP-247
would be brought back into containment,
preventing further bloodshed. Kowalski would
be given a posthumous medal of bravery for his
selfless actions in the line of duty, as well
as a generous stipend to his grieving family.
By this point, you’re probably wondering: How
can a harmless kitten cause so much carnage,
mayhem, and despair? The answer is simple: It’s
not a kitten at all, it’s a fully-grown female
Bengal Tiger, nine feet and 400 pounds of pure
muscle, with four inch claws, four inch canines,
and an inbuilt killer instinct. But
due to an anomalous memetic effect,
247 can only ever be perceived as a sweet,
tiny housecat. But even worse, due to its
additional cognitohazardous properties, almost
everyone who sees 247 is compelled to approach,
and begin doting and fawning over it.
And that’s exactly how it gets its prey.
Its memetic properties are actually so flawless
that, regardless of Foundation countermeasures,
it has never been perceived as anything other
than a kitten. It’s actually only through forensic
analysis into things like bite and claw marks left
on victims, measurements of weight, and abnormal
water displacement in aqueous environments
that we can tell it’s really a tiger at all.
For a brief period, SCP-148 - a metal
that seems to counteract cognitohazards
and mind-warping anomalies - was used in the
containment of this Euclid-class creature,
but these measures were abandoned after SCP-148
proved to have a negative impact on nearby
Foundation staff after prolonged exposure. Now,
strict protocols of surveillance and distancing
are required to prevent hapless Foundation staff
members from being lured to their doom by 247.
The head researcher on the SCP-247 case wanted
to conduct a series of experiments on SCP-247,
hoping to find more about the interplay of its
unique traits with other members of the animal
kingdom. Two control animals were brought
in, to represent the duality of SCP-247:
Control A was a yellow kitten, roughly
matching 247’s apparent shape and size.
Control B was a fully-grown Bengal Tiger,
representing 247’s actual shape and size.
A mixed-breed, cat-chasing terrier was brought
in for the first test. It immediately followed
Control A around, barking wildly until
it retreated up a tree. Unsurprisingly,
it fled in terror from Control B, cowering in
the corner. Control B paid no mind to the dog,
perhaps considering it beneath its attention,
even as prey. With SCP-247, the dog initially ran
towards it, barking, until it was only five meters
away. At this point, 247 let out an irritated
mewling noise, and the dog fled to the corner
in terror, suddenly aware of its true nature.
For test number two, a male tabby
kitten was brought in. As expected,
it simply played with Control A, and
was terrified of Control B. In the
first part of the test with 247, the anomalous
attributes of the creature led to some surreal,
mind-bending footage. At multiple
points, 247 picked up the other kitten,
as an adult female tiger might do with a cub,
and lifted it higher than 247 seemed to be
capable of. It was like watching a glitch
in real time. In a second part of the test,
the kitten immediately fled in terror,
suggesting 247 can control how it’s perceived.
Next came a deer, prey typical of a Bengal
Tiger. Neither Control B nor 247 were fed
for three days prior to this experiment,
and both killed and ate the deer. However,
curiously, 247 killed the deer with a single,
merciful bite to the neck before eating,
compared to its more brutal methods with
human targets. And when this experiment
was repeated with 247 after it hadn’t been
starved, it showed little interest in the
deer until it became hungry again, suggesting
it inherently prefers human or human-like prey.
This theory was further reinforced during
tests with a chimpanzee. The chimp fell
under 247’s cognitohazardous spell, and
began to pet it. Seven minutes later,
247 attacked and brutally devoured
the chimp, as it would its human prey.
But strangely, the most frightening result
of all came when SCP-247 was paired with
an adult male Bengal Tiger. They engaged in
standard mating behavior, which later led to
the duo reproducing a new creature - designated
SCP-247-1 - which had all the anomalous traits
of SCP-247. But the frightening realizations
don’t stop there. Studies into genetic material
provided by SCP-247 shows slight deviation from
a typical Bengal Tiger's genotype, suggesting
contamination from another creature that mated
with one of its non-anomalous tiger parents.
For context, tiger broods
have an average of three cubs,
but can have as many as seven - a
common practice, given how tiger cubs
are vulnerable to cannibalism from rival
adult males looking to court the females.
This leads to only one frightening conclusion:
There could be more creatures just like SCP-247
out there, apex predators that seem to the
untrained eye like cute, harmless kittens.
They could be anywhere, and if they’re close
enough to each other or other non-anomalous
tigers, they could breed even further,
becoming the scariest invasive urban
species you’ve ever seen. Because, after all,
we know what their preferred prey is now.
So next time you see a cute little orange
tabby cat and feel the instinct to pet it,
take a second to think about it. It
may be the last thing you ever do.
Did you hear that not so long ago,
a five-year-old boy went up against
twelve of Russia’s greatest chess grandmasters
- And do you know what happened? He lost every
single match. That’s because winning
at chess, dear viewers, isn’t easy.
Chess is an ancient game of strategy, cunning,
and skill. It’s not just about thinking one
step ahead of your opponent, that’s not going
to be enough. Make a wrong prediction and you
could end up sacrificing one of your pieces,
as well as vital space on the board.
But thinking two to three steps ahead,
beating your adversary’s moves before they’ve even
been made. Now there’s a viable strategy. Tricky,
but viable; after all, if it was easy, we’d
all be Queen’s Gambit level chess prodigies.
Eric Matthews had never been good at the game,
but he had a pretty substantial reason to keep
trying. And that reason’s name was Brian
Matthews, his father. You see, for as long
as Eric could remember, his dad had regarded
a high level of skill on the chessboard to be
a sign of intellectual superiority. Intelligence
was something that Brian put quite a considerable
value on, given that he was a professor at a
university in their home county in England.
Some of Eric’s earliest memories were of playing
chess with his dad, usually on a Friday night when
Brian got home after a week of giving lectures to
the next generation of scholars. Obviously, with
his son at such a young age, the professor would
take it easy on Eric, playing in a much laxer
fashion, focusing instead on teaching the boy
the basics of the game. And, for a time at least,
it was good. It was a rare time that Eric and his
academic father could spend bonding, after all,
with his mother gone, his dad was all he had.
But as the years passed, the game changed.
By the time Eric was a teenager, Brian
had stopped pulling his punches on the
chessboard. He had hoped his son would build on
what he’d learned when they played in the past,
using those skills to best his dad on the
board. But to Eric, playing chess had never
been about a purely educational experience; it
was more about spending time with his old man.
Time after time, the young man’s pawns fell
prey to Brian’s expertly considered and far more
competitive moves. Try as he might, Eric couldn’t
best his dad. He tried his best, and never stopped
putting the effort into every game, but thinking
too hard about one possible plan of attack left
him wide open to a counter-strategy from the
professor. Over and over again he landed himself
in checkmate, or made illegal moves without
even realizing it, every time earning criticism
and chastisement from his scholarly father.
Every game it got worse, it was like Eric
could feel his father’s gaze and the weighty
expectations behind it with each move he made
across the board. There were so many nights
where he wondered if it would be better to
give up entirely, to knock down his own
king and concede. But how could he ever
find any other shared interests with his
dad beyond the two of them playing chess?
It had become a lifeline, tethering father
and son together, and to cut it now left
Eric uncertain if he’d sink or be able to swim
alongside Brian. He had long admired his father,
his achievements in academia were impossible
to avoid, with more framed certificates hung
up on the walls than there were photos of
the pair of them together. But the shadow
it cast over him made Eric desperate to
keep this one shred of common ground alive.
Eric wasn’t the type to give up, despite how much
of an uphill struggle the situation felt like.
Taking a leaf out of his professor father’s
scholarly ways, he decided to learn the game
inside and out, every known move and strategy. He
would research the entire history of chess itself,
if that’s what it took to play with
the same skill as his dear old dad.
Over the coming weeks, Eric checked out every
book at his local library on the subject;
Beginner’s Guides, Advanced Rulebooks, and even
a few volumes on notable players throughout the
extensively long history of the game.
Along the way, a chapter of a certain
book stood out to Eric. It described a chess
prodigy from Russia, who had created an early
mechanical chess device known as ‘The Samurai’.
It had been designed to be a traveling curiosity,
and would sit playing chess games against
volunteers taken from a spectating audience,
each one of them having forked over some of their
hard-earned money to watch this man-made wonder.
The Russian chess prodigy’s young daughters also
had a love for the game. Seeing that gave Eric a
pang of jealousy, wondering if those daughters
had as much trouble playing their own father
as he did with Brian. But at least there was
an underlying shred of hope there too, if this
father and his daughters could bond over chess,
maybe there was a chance for Eric and his dad too.
Sadly, it’s one thing to try and learn
all the facts you can about chess. It’s
an entirely different beast to put all
that information to use and apply it to
an actual game. Despite having read every book
he could get his hands on, Eric still couldn’t
best Brian at the board. It was like nothing
had changed, his father barely noticed when
Eric tried to replicate move sets he’d read
up on, and still managed to not only counter
those moves but check his queen in the process.
So, practice, Eric thought. After all, practice
was supposedly meant to make perfect, right?
The plan was simple if he practiced his chess
moves enough times, and figured out how he could
call on what he’d learned, then he might stand a
chance at winning when he and his dad played each
other. There was just one hiccup to the plan:
Eric needed someone to practice against. The only
other person in the house was Brian, meaning it
was that hiccup that turned into a problem almost
big enough to stop Eric in his tracks. That is,
until he went into his father’s lab.
It was under the house itself,
a sort of sub-level, maybe used as a basement
or cellar by the previous owners. But since
Professor Matthews and his son had lived there,
the entire room had been remodeled into an at-home
laboratory. Not a terribly advanced one, of
course, this was the early nineties, after
all. A majority of Brian’s time, even when he
was at home instead of working at the university,
was spent on his own, downstairs in the lab.
Eric had gone down there in search of his dad,
to ask him if there was anyone whom he knew who
he could practice and develop his chess skills
with. But, instead, what he found down there
was the last thing he expected to see. Not that
he had any clue exactly what it was, at first.
The… thing was some kind of bizarre contraption,
a collection of components that didn’t seem
to be in any logical configuration. However,
it was primarily comprised of something that Eric
recognized all too well: a chess table. This one
was metal, steel to be precise, and seemed to
be hooked up to some sort of computer. While,
back in the nineties, computers were hardly as
commonplace as they are now, Eric had seen a
fair few at school and the library. Although
this one was different, it seemed… old. Far
older than Eric thought computers had been
around for; as far as he knew, they’d only
really come to prominence in the mid-eighties.
But this computer looked like it pre-dated even
that period. Noticing another part of the
contraption – a large steam engine with
the words ‘Manufactured by Maudslay, Sons
& Field, established 1840’ engraved on one
side – made it seem that this whole device
had been around since the Victorian era.
The next part that caught his eye was the chess
pieces themselves, each one standing neatly in
its place on the board. They looked delicate,
intricately carved from some smooth substance.
For a moment, Eric toyed with the thought
of how they could even be made from bone,
noting how each pawn, knight, rook, bishop,
king and queen were all about the size of a
human finger bone. He dismissed the idea;
nobody would ever do something like that.
Eric grabbed a sheet covering a larger component
hooked up to the mess. Lifting it away in a swift
pull, it unveiled what was sitting beneath: a full
suit of 18th Century Samurai armor. Eric looked
closer at the embellishments on the surface of
the pauldrons; he was no expert on Feudal Japan,
but it looked authentic enough to be the real
thing, if not a very close approximation.
Taking a look at the collection of oddities
all tethered together in his father’s lab,
a certain detail of all his chess research came
to the forefront of Eric’s mind. The armor had
given it away: this was ‘The Samurai’ – or, at
the very least, a least a crude, homemade version
of it that his dad had put together. But if it
worked, it was also something to practice against.
It didn’t take Eric long to start tinkering with
the contraption, trying to get it to work. All
the while, the question of why his dad owned
such a thing kept drumming up noise in the back
of his head. Had Brian built it, or was this the
original made by that Russian chess prodigy? Was
this machine the reason that Eric’s dad possessed
such an unbeatable skill at chess? And would using
it give him the edge he needed to best him
at the game and earn his father’s respect?
After what felt like hours upon hours of trial and
error with a machine he could barely comprehend,
Eric seemed to have cracked it. As far as
he could tell, the steam engine powered the
whole contraption and could be set to five
different speeds, labeled on the side in
roman numerals. The power from the engine
was then fed to some kind of sophisticated
mechanism that was within the suit of samurai
armor, allowing it to move, and what appeared
to be a series of electromagnets that moved
the chess pieces and kept them on the board.
Flicking it onto the third-highest of the five
speed levels, the machine whirred into life;
the sounds of creaking, and grinding of
metal filled the lab. Kneeling opposite,
Eric went to make the first move… only to stop
himself. It wasn’t that he’d changed his mind
about practicing against the Samurai, but because
of the speed he’d set it to. Determining that the
settings must have correlated to difficulty
levels, Eric figured that if he really wanted
to get the most rigorous practice, to really
hone his chess moves, he needed to commit fully.
Reaching for the dial, he turned the device up
to its fifth and highest speed, then made his
first move. He pushed one of the bone-colored
pawns forward by a single square and waited.
A split second passed, and the arm of the early
automaton responded with its first countermove. It
was quick, almost moving with the same natural
fluidity and speed as an actual human being;
albeit still with a little bit of creaking,
and some slight, clockwork-like stutters. But
it worked nonetheless, the machine could play.
The tension over the first game was palpable,
forming a layer of sweat over Eric’s forehead.
Every whirr and tick of the machine gave the
impression they were playing with a stop clock
timing each of their moves, adding to the urgency.
Despite this, Eric Matthews tried his best to
stay calm. This was practice after all, a dry run,
not the inevitable game he’d play against his dad.
With every move he made, his heart drummed against
his ribs, uncertain he’d made the right call. Each
time the robotic hand cruelly knocked one of his
pieces away, Eric felt the surge of frustration,
but told himself to quell it. He kept focused,
used what he’d researched to adapt and respond
accordingly to each of the machine’s moves, until…
Checkmate.
He’d beaten it – he
might have lost everything save for a knight, a
rook, his king and queen – but he had won. Trapped
without anywhere else to move on the board, the
metal finger of the automaton conceded the game,
knocking over its own king in resignation.
Panting, heart racing from the sheer excitement
of being on the winning side of a game, Eric
hurriedly gathered up and reset all the pieces.
He had to go again, not just so he could be
certain it wasn’t a fluke, but to make sure he
had what it took to take on his professor father.
Back and forth Eric went with the chess machine,
over and over again. They were fairly evenly
matched, it seemed. Eric won the second game,
only to be best on the next two. But it was
some time afterward – he had lost count of
exactly how many rounds later – that things
started to change. Maybe it was the age and
condition of the Victorian era chess computer, the
natural wear and tear stopping it from functioning
properly. But Eric noticed the Samurai
started to make moves that were illogical,
that practically offered him the upper hand
with no discardable strategy behind them.
Then, its movements became flat-out illegal,
disregarding the directions and number of squares
each different piece was allowed to move. Before
long, it was moving them erratically around the
chessboard, refusing to cooperate and forcing
Eric to call an end to the day’s practicing.
Unfortunately, it wouldn’t be the end of the
unusual things that would happen that day.
“Did you send me that weird email?” was the first
question Eric’s dad asked him when he returned
home, looking noticeably under the weather.
Confused, Eric said he had no idea what his
father was talking about. Professor Matthews
then went on to describe what he’d received on
his work computer. It had been an email, with a
file attached to it named ‘shakhmaty’, a word in
Russian that translates to ‘chess’. Embedded in
the email below – although it had taken a long
time to load being opened on a 1990s computer
– there had apparently been a photo as well.
“It was rather odd, Eric,” Brian went on. “Quite
unnerving to tell the truth. Black and white,
all sort of distorted and stretched.
But it looked like two young girls,
one grinning and the other screaming. I’ve been
feeling… well, not quite myself since I saw it.”
With that, Brian excused himself, stating
he’d been suffering from headaches and a high
temperature, and as a result, needed to go and
lay down. It wasn’t like his father to get ill,
Eric thought, but of course, he had no
reason to assume it was anything serious.
Probably just a spate of fatigue after a
long day of teaching at the university,
no cause for concern. If only that’s all it was.
Within a few hours, Brian was completely restless,
so unable to sleep that simply taking a nap
was impossible. He kept calling to Eric,
complaining of the sound of childlike laughter
coming from somewhere in the house, but his son
hadn’t heard anything. By the time the sun went
down, Eric was trying to calm his dad down through
a rush of intense anxiety that gripped him.
Brian had claimed to be hallucinating,
seeing the warped faces of two girls
that frightened him half to death.
It was getting late, long past the time they
usually played chess together, but for now,
Eric’s mind was focused solely on helping his
dad. For a while, he seemed to be able to calm his
father down, only to realize Brian wasn’t settled
at all. He was awake, eyes open, fully conscious,
but wasn’t responding at all to Eric asking
if he was alright. Instead, the accomplished
academic just stared blankly into space.
Eric had been up all night, exhausted,
worried for Brian’s safety, and completely
clueless about what was happening to him.
After a while of being non-responsive, his
dad seemed to regain a little bit of lucidity
once more, but his behavior was erratic.
“Take me back to work, I need to get on my
computer!” Brian demanded of his son.
When Eric refused, that’s when his
dad got angry, and agitated.
Professor Brian Matthews was
sadly found dead within the next few months.
Several months later, as the sole executor of
his father’s estate and last living relative, Eric
had to be the one to go through his dad’s personal
belongings. Volumes upon volumes of thick academic
books, his smart, scholarly clothes. The house was
almost clear now, save for one thing that was left
in the basement lab. Flicking on the light switch,
Eric looked at the Samurai sitting motionless,
still uncovered after their last practice game.
He’d sold off the chess pieces to a collector
in New York, now it was just an empty oddity.
Eric placed a king on the board, one of the
ones that he and his dad had used when they
played each other. With a gentle flick of his
finger, he toppled it, resigning to the strange
automaton and leaving it there in the laboratory.
He wasn’t sure how, but he had some kind of gut
feeling that this chess machine had somehow been
responsible for his father’s fate. Of course,
Eric had no idea what the device actually was, and
what… or who lay beneath its whirring metal parts.
SCP-1875 is the designation given to this
machine now, and has been ever since the
Foundation recovered it not long after Eric sold
his father’s house. They were able to learn much
more about it than young Mr. Matthews, or even the
late Professor Matthews, ever had. Not just how to
make it work or what its function was, but who
had built it… and who had been used to build it.
Although details of his real name
eluded the Foundation’s top researchers,
they were able to uncover newspaper articles
about the device from all over Russia, America,
and England, dating back to the early
1900s. The Russian chess prodigy who’d
invented it and toured the chess-playing
machine around, had used some interesting
components to make his automaton. Maybe they
were where it derived its skill at the game,
and its apparent temperament when the device
was made to play at maximum speed for too long.
He had used his daughters to make the machine.
Deep within the heart of this early form of
computer, the two girls brain tissue had been
hooked up to the electromagnets. The machine’s
moves were theirs; each pawn or rook shifting
across the black and white squares of the board,
every rule or strategy their prodigy
father had taught, it all determined
how the device played. Their minds, taken
from their skulls, were now the analytical
engine of their father’s creation. The bones of
their fingers, he'd carved into chess pieces.
Over the coming weeks, the Foundation naturally
ran their usual slew of tests on SCP-1875,
playing multiple games of chess against it. Every
time, they increased the machine’s five levels of
speed, until it started behaving erratically
while on the highest setting. Shortly after,
every member of personnel working on SCP-1875
received a bizarre email. It contained a file,
named with the Russian word for chess…
And a photograph; of the stretched, distorted,
smiling, and screaming faces of two young
girls. Faces that you might be seeing very soon…